QUIRK NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL. HURRY
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG. USER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO
SMITH. STONE TAMED BALLOT AREAS
VIA PUMA VOEPEL WALDRON BOARD
WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. WE ASK THAT
YOUR GRACE AND BLESSINGS TO BE
BESTOWED UPON THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN CALLED TO SERVE.
OUR STATE. AND IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. HELP
THEM TO REPRESENT THEIR COST TO
THEIR CONSTITUENTS WISELY. WITH
AN EYE TOWARD SAFEGUARDING THE
DEEPER TRUTHS OF HUMAN LIFE
.COM ONLY FROM YOU. BLUSTER
REGIONS THAT THEY REPRESENT
BLESS EVERYONE ON THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR HELP OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TO ENACT LAWS THAT WILL UPHOLD
THE VALUES OF PEACE AND JUSTICE
IN OUR STATE. I MEAN. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
COOLEY. PLEASE JOIN ME AS ONE
BODY INDIVISIBLE IN THIS MOMENT
WITH THE PLAN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. TO
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GYM SACRAMENTO TUESDAY JUNE
FOURTH TO JUNE FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS IN THE RED AT ONE
PM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE IF YOU
SIMPLY PRESIDING SHE PLUCKS YOU
PROPERTY DEATHS RECORDED OWN
READING. ROLL CALL THE ROLL IS
CALLED. AS MOVES AND MISTER
FLORA SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE NO ABSENCES FOR TODAY'S
SESSION.
MS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO
ALLOW SOMEONE MEMBERS BIRTH
CERTI AND WICKS TO HAVE GUESTS
SEATED AT THEIR DESKS TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GIPSON
AND BLOOM TO SPEAK ON THE
GERMAN AND MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM EIGHTY SIX. SB FOUR
EIGHTY STERN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
THERE IS A LETTER BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY AT THE
DESK CONCERNING SB ONE TWENTY
NINE SKINNER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY TWO C. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PRINT THE VOTER TO PRINT THE
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
TO TAKE UP ITEM TWENTY EIGHT S.
B. ONE FOUR FOUR PORTANTINO
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING. I
GET WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES. TO WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TíNH TO TAKE
THEM UP TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIRD READING SB ONE SIXTY. SB
ONE FIFTY SIX. SB ONE FIFTY
THREE AND S. B. ONE THIRTY
THREE. MR FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR
WE WILL HOLD NOW SINCE IT HAS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING. MS REYES MOOSE.
AND MISTER CHOW SECONDS. BONTA
THE ROLE SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTES
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. RAMOS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MS
FLORETTE MISTER FLORA IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE MS RACES ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR FLORA.
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE ON. WOW OKAY MS
S. IS ASKING FOR AND I AM
MISTER FLORA AND NO. WELL THE
CLOSER ALL EYES FORTY FIVE
NOTES ELEVEN. RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORKERY SENATE
BILL 211-363-7743 SIXTY WITH A
MEMBERS THREE NINETY FIVE OF
THE MEMBERS SIX THIRTY SEVEN
WITH A MINUTE SIX FIFTY WITH
THE MINISTRY 344-728-2730 FIVE
MINUTES FORTY THREE WITH A
MEMBERS FIFTY WITHIN MINUTES.
TWENTY SIX TO THIRTY NINE TO
SIXTY NINE FIVE SEVENTY FOUR
FIVE TWO FOUR SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT THIRTEEN EIGHT
FOURTEEN EIGHT TWENTY FOURS TWO
NINETY FIVE SEVENTY TWO SIX
TWENTY SIX. SIX NINETY FOUR
FOUR THREE WITH A MINUTES ONE
FORTY FOUR FIVE TEN WITH A
MEMBERS EIGHT ONE OF THE
MEMBERS AND CYNICAL IT'LL FREE
WITHIN MINUTES. ALL BILLS WILL
BE DEEMED READ. AND ALL
AMENDMENTS. DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS. WE ARE READY TO TAKE
UP WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE SB
ONE FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL ONE FORTY FOUR
BY CENTER PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND ACCORDING TO TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. THIS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM SO PROUD TO
PRESENT ON THIS FLOOR SB ONE
FORTY FOUR JOIN AUTHORED BY MY
SENATE COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE
COLLEAGUE IN GLENDALE ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE FROM ANY MARINA DEL
REY AND MYSELF. SB ONE FORTY
FOUR EXPANDS THE FILM AND
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. AND
WORKER WORKFORCE DIVERSITY IT
EXPANDS THE EXISTING CREDIT BY
NINETY MILLION FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. IT INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION FOR NEW FILL
INFRASTRUCTURE CREDITS. FOR THE
SOUND STAGES THEREBY INCREASING
PRODUCTION IT CREATES A TO EARN
A HIGH PERCENT OF CREDIT
SUPPORT NEEDS BELOW THE LINE
AND ABOVE THE LINE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GOALS THAT THEY
THEMSELVES SET AND WHICH ARE.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW. I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE SUPPORT OF THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION AND THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
ON THESE EFFORTS AND I'M MOST
GRATEFUL FOR THE BICAMERAL
PARTNERSHIP THE MY SENATE
COLLEAGUES FROM GLENDALE AND I
HAVE FORMED. HE REPRESENTS A
DISTRICT THAT IS HOME TO STUDIO
AND TELEVISION COMPANIES THAT
HAVE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES. WELL I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT IS HOME TO MANY
OF THE ABOVE THE LINE CREATIVES
WRITERS PRODUCERS DIRECTORS AN
ONSCREEN TALENT AND OF COURSE.
TALENTED AND HARD WORKING BELOW
THE LINE WORKERS FROM SOUND
ENGINEERS GRIPS MAKE UP AND
WARDROBE DESIGNERS AND SO ON.
CALIFORNIA MUST BE COMPETITIVE
TO ENSURE THESE JOBS DON'T
LEAVE THE STATE.THE BY CAMEL
PARTNERSHIP IN THROUGH THE WORK
DONE AND BUDGETS OF FOR WITH
REGARDS TO OVERSIGHT OF THE
FILM TAX COMMISSION. SB ONE
FORTY FOUR HAS ALLOWED US TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ON INCREASING GOOD
MIDDLE CLASS UNION JOBS IN THE
FILM INDUSTRY. RETAINING AND
BRING ABOUT PRODUCTION TO
CALIFORNIA AND MOVING FORWARD
ENSURING THAT THE FILM TAX
COMMISSION HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
BEGIN TO CREATE A REAL PLAN OF
ACTION. IN WHICH DATA
COLLECTION IS INTER WOVEN AND
IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
LEGISLATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION MAKING
PROCESS AND ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA TAX DOLLARS ARE
REFLECTION. OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENTS IN THE FILM TAX
CREDIT OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
IS JUST ABOUT. EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THE RETURN ON OUR
INVESTMENT IN THE IMPACT TO OUR
ECONOMY HAS BEEN AT THE TUNE OF
SIX. BILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S A
GREAT INVESTMENT. WHAT WE CAN
DO BETTER. EARLIER THIS YEAR
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
WHO HAPPENS TO BE MY SEATMATE.
CHAIR TO SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING ON UNSEEN MEDINA IN
HOLLYWOOD. WHICH TRENDING
HASHTAGS LIKE OSCARS SO WHITE
WHAT WE HEARD ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTIES TO ENTER THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY WITH
APPALLING. AND YET NOT NEW. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN A USC STUDY
PUBLISHED A REPORT EXAMINING
TWELVE HUNDRED TOP GROSSING
FILMS FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND THE
REPRESENTATION OF LATINOS BOTH
ON SCREEN AND BEHIND THE
CAMERA. OF THE TOP ONE HUNDRED
GROSSING DOMESTIC FEATURES IN
THE PAST TWELVE YEARS LET ME
KNOW CHARACTERS MAKE UP ONLY
FOUR POINT 5% OF ALL SPEAKING
ROLES. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE
AND JUST THE ONE HUNDRED TOP
FILMS. FORTY SEVEN OF THE ONE
HUNDRED WERE MISSING LET ME
pMISSING AT THE MATH NINETY FIVE
DID NOT FEATURE ANY LET ME KNOW
CHARACTER WITH A DISABILITY.
NINETY EIGHT WERE MISSING AT
THE NOTES ON THE LGBT COMMUNITY
AND ONLY 4% WERE DIRECTORS 3%
OR PRODUCERS AND ONLY ONE
LATINO DIRECTOR ACROSS THE
ENTIRE TWELVE HUNDRED FILMS.
47% OF THE TWELVE HUNDRED FILMS
COMPLETELY ERASED LATINO
CHARACTERS. DATA DOES NOT LIE.
THE SAME SENTIMENTS CAN BE
SHARED ACROSS THE BOARD WITH
API BLACK AND LGBT COMMUNITIES
IN THE INTERSECTION ALITY OF
VARIOUS GROUPS. MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO SIXTEEN
MILLION LATINOS CLOSE 240% OF
THE POPULATION. MAKING UP THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE. WHAT THE
COUNTRY LATINOS ARE THE LARGEST
AND FASTEST GROWING POPULATION
AND PAY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN TAXES.
INCLUDING A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
BILLION IN FEDERAL INCOME TAXES
AS WELL AS EIGHTY SIX BILLION
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES. AND
GUESS WHAT WE LOVE GOING TO THE
MOVIES YET WE ARE NOT REFLECTED
IN THE VERY FILMS. THAT WE
WATCH. SB ONE FORTY FOUR IS A
NEW MODEL. IT WILL EXPAND
EXISTING TAX CREDITS IT WILL
INVEST IN STUDIO INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL CREATE A PATHWAY FOR
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY FOR BOTH
BELOW AND ABOVE THE LINE
WORKFORCE IT WILL ENSURE DATA
COLLECTION IT WILL KEEP AND
BRING BACK PRODUCTION THE
CALIFORNIA IT WILL CREATE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WORKERS FOR
THIS INDUSTRY AND ULTIMATELY
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA REMAINS
THE GLOBAL LEADER. IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT PRODUCTION SB ONE
FORTY FOUR CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES OF WHICH EQUITY
IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
CONVERSATION OF COOL WHEN WHERE
AND HOW. STORIES ARE TOLD. SO
WHEN YOU AREN'T RELAXING AT
HOME. STREAMING ON YOUR SHOW.
OR YOU GO TO THE MOVIE THEATER
AND YOU SIT BACK AND ENJOY THE
FULL CINEMATIC EXPERIENCE. JEFF
NO. THAT CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
EVERY EFFORT TO SHIP AN
INDUSTRY TO BE MORE REFLECTIVE
OF ITS AUDIENCE AND TO ME
MEMBERS THAT IS PROGRESS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND APPEALING PART OF CRAFTING
TAX POLICY IS WHEN WE CAN
INVEST IN AND SUPPORT A
HOMEGROWN INDUSTRY ONE THAT WE
CONSIDER OUR OWN ONE THAT GREW
UP IN OUR STATE. AND ONE THAT
WE ARE PROUD OF AND ONE THAT
GENERATES GOOD PAYING JOBS AND
THAT WILL HELP MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS. WELL THAT
DESCRIPTION CERTAINLY CAN BE
APPLIED TO THE FILM AND TV
INDUSTRY. AND I WAS PROUD TO CO
AUTHOR A COUPLE OF THE PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS CREDIT THAT
WE'RE CONSIDERING TODAY. THAT
DESCRIPTION THAT I JUST LISTED
FOR YOU. MOST CERTAINLY CAN
ALSO BE APPLIED TO THE
BIOTECHNOLOGY AND LIFE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
GREW UP IN AND STILL LIVE IN
SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO WHICH IS
THE ACTUAL BIRTHPLACE OF
BIOTECHNOLOGY. MY DISTRICT IS
NOW HOME TO WELL OVER TWO
HUNDRED. OF THESE BIOTECH AND
LIFE SCIENCES COMPANIES THAT
UTILIZE UNION LABOR WHEN
EXPANDING THEIR CAMPUSES IT IS
NOW VERY MUCH THE GENERAL
EMPLOYER ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THESE ARE CAMPUSES WERE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH IS BEING
DONE TO FIND LIFESAVING CURES
AND TREATMENTS AND THERAPIES.
YOU RECALL THAT WHEN KOBE HIT.
ANY ECONOMY CAME TO A HALT AND
HEFTY DEFICITS WERE PROJECTED
ACTION WAS TAKEN TO SUSPEND
THESE LIFE SCIENCES COMPANIES
ABILITY TO UTILIZE THE RD TAX
CREDIT AND NET OPERATING LOSS
OPTIONS. SAYS WE KNOW THE
BUDGET IS NOW IN SURPLUS AND
THIS ACTION WE'RE TAKING TODAY
IS TO EXPAND. THE FILM AND
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT. BUT SO
FAR THIS BUILDING HAS NOT YET
NEARLY RESTORED THE PRE
EXISTING LIFE SCIENCES R&D AT A
WHILE CREDIT. WELL I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT BENEFITS
THE CALIFORNIA COMPANIES THAT
MADE ENTERTAINMENT. AND
CREATIVE DISTRACTION POSSIBLE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. MY HOPE
IS THAT WE CAN ALSO FIND THE
LOGIC IN RESTORING THE PRE
PANDEMIC TAX CREDITS TO THE
LIFE SCIENCES INDUSTRY WHICH IS
ACTUALLY WORKING ON VACCINES.
AND THERAPIES FOR COVERT. AND A
RANGE OF DISEASES. IF BUDGETS
AND IN THIS CASE TAX POLICY OR
STATEMENT OF OUR VALUES. SURELY
THERE IS ROOM FOR BOTH POLICIES
AND PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THERE SHOULD BE ROOM FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION OF THE
EFFICACY OF NOT ONLY THESE
CREDITS BUT ALL OF OUR TAX
CREDITS. THE GEOGRAPHIC BALANCE
IN TAX POLICY AND WHICH
INDUSTRIES TRULY WILL BE THE
DRIVERS OF SUSTAINED ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. IN CALIFORNIA. AND
SHOULD I SAY FUTURE BUDGET.
SURPLUSES AT LEAST WE HOPE. SO
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE BUT I
ALSO ASK FOR A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE CONVERSATION
ABOUT COHERENCE IN OUR TAX
POLICY GOING FORWARD. TO KEEP
ALL OF CALIFORNIA ECONOMICALLY
COMPETITIVE WITH THE MANY
STATES THAT COVET. THESE JOBS
THANK YOU ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU MR MILLER AND MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND- I JUST WANT TO RISE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE WANT TO COMPLEMENT. OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM MARINA DEL
REY FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS I THINK ARE CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES. LAID OUT THE CASE
VERY THOROUGHLY I JUST WANT TO
ADD ONE POINT TO THIS I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. AND I WANT TO MAKE
THE POINT THERE IS NOT THIS IS
NOT ABOUT CELEBRITIES THIS IS
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR DRY
CLEANERS PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
CATERS. SOUND ENGINEERS THE
INCREDIBLE FOLKS AND I GOT SEE
WHO ARE THE HEART AND SOUL OF
OUR CREATIVE ECONOMY AND OUR
DISTRICT IN ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY HERE. IN LOS ANGELES
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL HAVE
BROAD BENEFITS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES. VERY PRIVILEGE TO
CHAIR A SELECT COMMITTEE TO
HAVE A HEARING ON THIS ISSUE ON
THE TAX CREDITS LAST YEAR. WAS
ATTENDED BY ALL OF THE MEMBERS
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AND WE HEARD EXTRAORDINARY
TESTIMONY ABOUT NOT ONLY THE
MILLIONS OF DIRECT JOBS THAT
THIS TAX CREDIT CRATES. BUT THE
MILLIONS OF INDIRECT JOBS THE
MULTIPLIER EFFECT THROUGHOUT
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
EXTRAORDINARY. WE KNOW THAT THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY. IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY ARE PART
OF THE DNA OF CALIFORNIA THEY
ARE PART OF WHAT MAKES THE
GOLDEN STATE SPECIAL THIS IS
SOMETHING WITH PROVEN BENEFITS
AND I WOULD STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
MISS PETRI NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HIM AS IRWIN STATUS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
CHIU RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
FORTY FOUR TODAY I KNOW
YESTERDAY IN OUR REVENUE TAX
HEARING THE AUTHOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. I MADE A VERY
COMPELLING CASE FOR WHY THESE
TAX CREDITS ARE SO IMPORTANT
FOR STIMULATING ECONOMIC GROWTH
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR CREATING GOOD JOBS AT BOTH
ABOVE AND BELOW THE LINE SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BUT I WILL NOTE. I'M
SIMILAR TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE BAY AREA I THINK WHEN WE
TAKE A STEP BACK AND CONSIDER
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF A
BROADER TAX POLICY. I AM LEFT
SCRATCHING MY HEAD A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE WE THINK ABOUT TAX
CREDITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FROM OUR LAST BUDGET YEAR AS
YOU MAY RECALL. I EARLY TWELVE
MONTHS AGO WE THOUGHT WE WERE
FACING A THIRTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT. WHICH
SOME TOUGH CHOICES INCLUDING.
IMPLEMENTING A CAP ON TAX
CREDITS ALL ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT ACTUALLY
INCLUDING THE FILM TAX CREDIT
INCLUDING THE CAL COMPETES TAX
CREDIT I. SO I WOULD URGE US IN
ADDITION TO MOVING FORWARD AND
I VOTING FOR THISBILL TODAY TO
CONSIDER REINSTATING THE TAX
CREDITS THAT EXISTED PRE
PANDEMIC. AND RESTORING THOSE
TAX CREDITS IN FULL THOSE ARE
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW IS
LIABILITIES ON OUR BALANCE
SHEET I THINK WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THAT. WE LIFT THOSE CAPS
NOW AND ENSURE THAT WE ARE
STIMULATING ECONOMIC GROWTH
CREATING GOOD JOBS IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY IN THE LIFE SCIENCES
SECTOR INTACT IN AEROSPACE.
INDUSTRIES AND REGIONS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY AT
RICHER I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
MESSAGE IN OUR SISTER GIVE SEND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
OF ONE FORTY FOUR AND THANK MY
SISTER FROM THE LOS ANGELES FOR
STANDING UP AND BRING IN THIS
OF COURSE. BEFORE US TODAY TO
EXPAND THE TAX CREDIT FOR THE
FILM INDUSTRY BUT ALSO SEEK TO
ENCOURAGE DIVERSITY. THIS IS IN
PART SPEAKS TO. THE HEART OF
THE EFFORT I CHAMPION THIS
YEAR- BUT UNFORTUNATELY- THE
BIT MY BILL WAS HELD- IN
COMMITTEE A. B. NINE EIGHTY SIX
THE- DIVERSITY FILM TAX CREDIT.
WHICH WOULD HAVE CREATED A TAX
CREDIT SPECIFICALLY. TO THE
INDEPENDENT FILM INDUSTRY TO
PROMOTE DIVERSITY. MEMBERS IT
IS CRITICAL CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE FILM STAR
FILM TAX CREDIT REFLECTS THE
TRUE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
HAVING DIVERSITY IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY TO MATCH WHAT
CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE CREATES A
SPACE FOR INCLUSION
UNDERSTANDING. AND ALSO IT
PROMOTES DIVERSITY AT THE SAME
TIME. MEMBERS WE ARE STRONG WE
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT- SENATE
BILL ONE FORTY FOUR- WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN- CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY
COME DOWN DIVERSITY IN THIS
INDUSTRY. I WANT TO LIVE MY
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SAND. SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
WE TALKED ABOUT IS MORE THAN
JUST. ENTERTAINERS IT'S ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE THAT
REFLECTS CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONLY
IN FRONT OF THE FIELD BEHIND
THE FIELD- FROM CATERING TO
CLEANING TO ALL THE THINGS THAT
MAKES UP THE FILM INDUSTRY.
CALIFORNIA CAN HAVE THAT
REFLECTION- CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
SEEN- IN THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND STRONGLY ASPEN I
VOTE ON SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISS BURKE
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
NOT ONLY IN MY CAPACITY AS
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION BUT ALSO
AS A BLACK WOMAN. AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR AND AS
SOMEONE WHOSE FAMILY HAS BEEN
DEEPLY AFFECTED BY RUN AWAY
FILM PRODUCTION. CALIFORNIANS
FILM TAX CREDIT IS A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD AND HAS GENERATED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY MORE THAN
SEVEN TIMES. THE INVESTMENT
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE IN THE
SIGNATURE INDUSTRY. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ITS
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THIS
VITAL CREDIT AND MAKING IT MORE
ROBUST. SB ONE FORTY FOUR
ENSURES THAT EXISTING
TELEVISION SERIES CONTINUE TO
BE FILMED IN THE STATE. AND THE
BILL'S NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
CREDIT WILL ENCOURAGE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PERMANENT
STUDIOS TO SECURE CALIFORNIA'S
FILMING FUTURE. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT CREDIT WILL
ALSO DIRECTLY LEAD TO HIGH
PAYING JOBS BOTH DURING
RENOVATION AND CONSTRUCTION AND
FOR YEARS TO COME. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR HER WORK ON THE
MEANINGFUL DIVERSITY MEASURE
INCLUDED. IN THIS BILL. NEW
JERSEY AND ILLINOIS TO HAVE
SOME OF THE STRICTER AND MOST
SUCCESS DIVERSITY MEASURE IN
THE BILL INDUSTRY AND IT IS WHY.
PAST TIME CALIFORNIA CATCH UP.
A RECENT REPORT FROM THE
NATIONAL RESEARCH GROUP SHOWED
THAT TO. IN THREE AFRICAN. SAY
THEY DON'T SEE THEM SO OR THE
CULTURE. IN MOVIES OR
TELEVISION. WITH 86% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS WANTING TO SEE MORE
OF THESE REPUTATIONS AND TOLD
STORIES ON THE SCREEN. THE
VIEWS ARE BACKED BY DATA
ACCORDING TO INFORMATION
REPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION BLACK CALIFORNIANS
ARE UNDER REPRESENTED IN THE
FILM INDUSTRY. MAKING UP ONLY
FIVE POINT 6% OF HIRES. WHILE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE. IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE ENTIRE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
ECOSYSTEM STILL NEEDS TO
IMPROVE ITS DIVERSITY. BUT
THESE ARE NOT THE ONLY REASONS
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. IT WAS
JUST A WEEK AGO MY DAUGHTER'S
FATHER STOOD IN MY HOUSE
HOLDING BACK TEARS. HE WAS
BROKEN HARD. DUE TO OUT OF
STATE PRODUCTION IN HIS
INDUSTRY HE HAS BEEN HOME LESS
THAN TWENTY OF THE LAST A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS.
MISSING HIS DAUGHTER'S SEVENTH
BIRTHDAY A FEW WEEKS AGO. THESE
ARE MOMENTS A PARENT CANNOT GET
BACK. WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE SAY
THIS BILLS LIKE THIS ARE JUST
ABOUT PLEASING A PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY I SAY YOU'RE WRONG. SB
ONE FORTY FOUR IS ABOUT THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT IS INDUSTRY EMPLOYS. IT'S
ABOUT THEIR FAMILIES. AT LEAST
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL MEANS TO
ME. THE FILM TAX CREDIT IS
SOMETHING WE CAN DO TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS EMPLOYED. AND
FAMILIES TOGETHER. SO TODAY FOR
MY DAUGHTER I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB ONE
FORTY FOUR. BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED OBSERVER.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
THE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD
OF THE. CLERK WILL LOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE I. SIXTY TWO
KNOWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
BUDGET BILLS TO TAKE UP. THESE
ARE RECIPES. WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE MR TANG WE'RE LOOKING
TO TAKE UP SB. ONE SIXTY. THIS
IS SB ONE SIXTY. THE CORPORATE
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER CHENEY
MAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB ONE SIXTY IS ON
ANOTHER CANNABIS TRAILER BILL
WHICH CONTAINS FIXES TO A
NUMBER OF ITEMS IN FROM SB ONE
FORTY ONE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO RESOLVE
ISSUES SO IN ADDITION TO THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS APPROPRIATE
THE BUDGET. THIS BILL WILL
ADDRESS OVER 80% OF THE
CANNABIS LICENSEE STILL HOLDING
PROVISIONAL LICENSES AND BRING
THE INDUSTRY INTO ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPLIANCE. WE STRUCK A BALANCE
FOR THE NEED BETWEEN. LICENSES
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH SEQUEL
WHILE PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT. SB ONE SIXTY ALSO
EXTEND THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
TO OFFER PROVISIONAL LICENSES.
FOR SMALL AND MEDIUM FARMERS
THE BILL EXTENDS THE ISSUANCE
OF PROVISIONAL LICENSES TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IT
FOR LOCAL WE OPERATE OPERATORS
THIS BILL EXTENDS THE DEADLINE
TO JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IN ADDITION SB ONE SIXTY
DELAYS THE DEADLINE BY WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE MUST CREATE A
PROCESS FOR LICENSED
CULTIVATORS TO ESTABLISH
APPELLATIONS. OF ORIGIN TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR CHANG MR
FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. A MEMBERS
TWO WEEKS AGO WE SENT EIGHTY
ONE FORTY ONE TO THE GOVERNOR
TO CONSOLIDATE THE STATE'S
CANNABIS REGULATORY SCHEME. BUT
LIKE THAT BILL SB ONE SIXTY A
NOR IS THE INPUT OF KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IT SEEKS TO
TIMELINE MANDATES TO UNEQUAL
TREATMENT IN THE INDUSTRY IT
SEEMS THE STATE CANNOT GET THIS
QUITE RIGHT. NOT ONLY WILL THIS
BILL POSE SIGNIFICANT STRESSES
ON INDUSTRY BUT IT COMPLICATES
THE LICENSING PROCESS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PUT THE MUCH
NEEDED LOCAL REVENUE AT RISK. I
REGION OF UP. MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YEAH THANK YOU
SPEAKER MEMBER JUST REAL
QUICKLY UNFORTUNATELY I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS PARTICULAR BILL
BECAUSE IT'S JUST ANOTHER
OBSTACLE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO COMPLY WITH THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSING PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW THE ILLICIT MARKET
HAS SUCH AN OVERWHELMING
DOMINANCE IN THIS MARKET. SHAME
ON US IF WE MAKE IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO COMPETE
AND COMPLY SHALL BE A STRONG NO.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO TODAY
TO SUPPORT SB ONE SIXTY. LET ME
BE CLEAR TO COMBAT ILLICIT
CANNABIS ACTIVITIES AND SHUT
DOWN THE BLACK MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA WE MUST REDUCE THE
BARRIERS IN LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES SPACE TO OBTAIN
THESE LICENSES PROVISIONAL
LICENSES ARE VITAL PIECE IN THE
LONG TERM OPERATION OF THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY REPRESENTING
THE VAST MAJORITY OF ALL
CURRENT CANNABIS LICENSES. SB
ONE SIX SIXTY MAKES NECESSARY
CLEANUP CHANGES TO HELP
LEGITIMATE CANNABIS BUSINESSES
OBTAIN PROVISIONAL LICENSES AS
THEY AWAIT APPROVAL FOR THEIR
ANNUAL LICENSE HOWEVER I WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION WE
ALLOCATED EARLY THIS YEAR
TWENTY TWO MILLION OF WHICH
WENT TO L. A. COUNTY TO ASSESS
THE MOST IMPACTED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS. FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSE HOLDERS IS
WHAT MAKES THESE CHANGES
EFFECTIVE ON TOP OF THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ESPECIALLY
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS BILL
FURTHER EXTENDS THE TIME LINE
FOR SOCIAL EQUITY LICENSE
APPLICANTS. AS WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESSED AND EQUAL ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THE
STIGMA ASSOCIATED CAMPUS SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE ONE
FEATURED IN SB ONE SIXTY HELP
ENSURE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY SUFFERED THE
EFFECTS OF THE WAR ON DRUGS CAN
BENT CAN ALSO BENEFIT FROM
THIS. ILLEGAL INDUSTRY. AS ONE
OF THE FOUNDING FATHERS OF
CANNABIS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS WHERE.
SEEING AT NO ADDITIONAL MISTER
COOLEY MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I GUESS
I'M ALSO ONE OF THE FOUNDING
FATHERS ON CANNABIS THIS IS A
VERY COMPLICATED FIELD WHICH IN
A SPAN OF FIVE YEARS WE'VE MADE
GREAT ADVANCES. AND YET IT IS
STILL A COMPLEX FIELD WE ARE
WORKING OUR WAY THROUGH THIS
BILL IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF THAT. AND I THINK THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO BE REFINEMENTS TO
THE YEARS AHEAD BUT ORIGINAL
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SZCZESNY MAKE CLOTHES
WE WISH WITH TECHNICAL OF THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS. HIS HAIR TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. THIS TAKES. FIFTY
FOUR. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS
THAT OF A.
WELL. THE CLOSER
ROLE TIDE OF A HIGHS FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS FOURTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY SIX. SB ONE FIVE SIX
CORKERY SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY
SIX BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
MAKING APPROPRIATION OR FORTY
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BELOW
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER CHANG
EMAIL PRINT THANK U. S. B. ONE
FIFTY SIX IMPLEMENTS THE SIX
BILLION DOLLAR PREPARATION OF
BROADBAND WITH THEIR WITHIN THE
BUDGET PACKAGE THERE ARE FOUR
PIECES TO THIS- BROADBAND
PACKAGE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE BIPARTISAN MEMBERS WHO
WORKED REPRESENTING URBAN RULE
CONCERNS FRIDAY CONCERNS FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE TO REALLY.
OF FLUSH OUT THIS PACKAGE THE
FIRST PIECE WITH A THREE POINT
TWO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
BUILD THE MIDDLE ILE FOR MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE ANY
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE GOING
INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES THERE'S
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
BUILD THE LAST MILE FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ACTUALLY HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BEFORE
WHATEVER REASON CAN'T GET IT TO
THAT PARTICULAR HOME OR OFFICE
OR- LOCATION. FOR SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR A LOAN LOSS
RESERVE TO FINANCE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR NONPROFIT AGENCY
AND LASTLY THERE IS A NARAL
SEQUEL EXEMPTION TO LAY
BROADBAND A LONG CURRENT
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN LAY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FIVE VOTE ON SB ONE FIFTY
SIX. MISTER FONG ERA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY SIX THE
PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT SO MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES WERE LEFT
WITHOUT RELIABLE INTERNET
CONNECTION NEEDED FOR
COMMUNICATION EDUCATION AND
TELEMEDICINE WE ALL WORKED WITH
A LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
FACT AS THEY STRUGGLE TO ASSIST
STUDENTS IN URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES TO GET RELIABLE
CONNECTIVITY. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK THAT SETS
A PATH TO CONNECTING OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BUT WE
NEED TO ENGAGE ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE NEEDED BROADBAND ACCESS IN
A TIME WHEN CAN ACTIVITY IS SO
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND
METRICS SO ARE RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND. I URGE AND I'VE UP.
THANK YOU MR FONG MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FIFTY SIX THIS IS A
HISTORIC INVESTMENT
PARTICULARLY AND BROADBAND AND
PUBLIC BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS PANDEMIC IS SHOWN THAT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS ONE OF THE
MOST PRESSING CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUES OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. IF YOU DON'T HAVE
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE INTERNET
ACCESS YOU CAN'T GET INTO THE
CLASSROOM IF YOU DON'T HAVE
RELIABLE INTERNET SERVICE YOU
CAN'T TELECOMMUTE AND GET INTO
THE WORKPLACE. FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE INTERNET SERVICE
THEY CAN'T SEE THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS THIS HAS IMPLICATIONS
FOR EDUCATION FOR EMPLOYMENT
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY FOR A FOR
HELP SO MANY AND RESPECTS. THIS
IS A HISTORIC INVESTMENT AND
PUBLIC BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE
MIDDLE MILE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE FREEWAYS AND THE
ROADS OF. INTERNET ACCESS AND
SO THIS IS A GAME CHANGER WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ASPIRATIONS OF THIS THIS
HISTORIC INVESTMENT IS ACTUALLY
TRANSLATED INTO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE TO ADDRESS THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. DR
WAITING HERE RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HERE THIS MORNING. THIS IS A
BIG DEAL. POTENTIALLY A BIG
DEAL. IN A LOT OF PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT- REALLY STRUGGLE WITH
THIS WE HAVE WE HAVE LOWER A
LOWER NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE ACCESS TO BROADBAND AND
MANY MANY MANY PEOPLE IN THE
STATE. I'VE KIDS AND ADULTS WHO
GO AND SIT IN PARKING LOTS AT
THE LIBRARY TO GET WIFI ACCESS
TO FILL OUT A JOB APPLICATION
OR AN APPLICATION FOR COLLEGE.
WE HAVE KIDS WHO HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET ACCESS TO FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING IN OUR
DISTRICT. WE PASSED A BILL ON
SET THAT THAT INCLUDED OUT
ELEMENTS ON TELEHEALTH. YET I
HAVE PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY WHO
CAN ACCESS TELEHEALTH BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. I'M GONNA BE
WATCHING THIS REALLY CLOSE I'M
GOING TO INVOKE MY INNER
STAYING HERE THIS MORNING FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW WHO STING
AS- SOME OF OUR YOUNGER MEMBERS-
EVERY BREATH YOU TAKE. EVERY
MOVE YOU MAKE. EVERY BOND YOU
BREAK. EVERY STEP YOU TAKE I'LL
BE WATCHING YOU AND THAT'S IS
DIRECTED AT TWO ENTITIES ONE
CALTRANS WHO HAS. A LOT TO GO
TO HELP PROVE THAT THEY CAN GET
THIS DONE FOR ME. AND THE
SECOND IS THE P. YOU SEE. THE
P. YOU SEE SAT I PASSED A BILL
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN.
THAT TOOK THREE YEARS TO GET
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
AND I'M CONVINCED IT WOULD
STILL BE SITTING ON SOMEONE'S
DESK NOW IF WE HADN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CALL OUT
SOMEBODY DURING THE SB NINE ONE
DISCUSSIONS. WHILE BACK I'M
PRETTY SURE THAT BILLS BILL
STILL WE SIT ON SOMEONE'S DESK
SO THIS IS A HUGE POTENTIAL MY
DISTRICT ONCE THIS WHAT WE WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND WE WANT
PEOPLE TO KEEP THE EYE ON THE
BALL AND I ASSURE YOU THAT I
WILL KEEP AN EYE ON THE BALL
AND I HOPE THAT THE REST OF YOU
WILL AS WELL AND I HOPE YOU'LL
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU DO DO DO DOCTOR WOULD- MS
DALLY. YOUR RECOGNIZE. IF YOU
DON'T GET THAT YOU NEED A
LISTENER POLICE A LITTLE MORE
MISSED OUT IN EUROPE. MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT TODAY OF SB ONE
FIFTY SIX I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S RULE NOR STATE IN
MY DISTRICT ARE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT MEET THE DEFINITION
OF UNSERVED AND HAVE VIRTUALLY
NO BROADBAND ACCESS. THIS IS
RUN ONE THIRD OF MY DISTRICT
POPULATION MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE
FELT THE EFFECTS OF NO
BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY FOR
DECADES BUT THE PANDEMIC ONLY
HIVE IT HIGHLIGHTED THE
SEVERITY OF THIS PROBLEM. LOCK
LACK OF BROADBAND ACCESS
COMPOUNDS EVERY CHALLENGE WE
FACE IS A REGION WHETHER IT'S
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES DISTANT
LEARNING OR PANDEMIC INDUCED
BUSINESS CLOSURES NO INTERNET
AND CELL SERVICE HAS MADE
RESPONDING TO THESE ISSUES.
THAT MUCH HARDER. IT'S PAST
TIME OUR RURAL AREAS WERE
PRIORITISED FOR BROADBAND AND
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE BIPARTISAN
PARTNERSHIP TO WORK TOWARDS A
SCHOOL. I WANT TO THANK THE
SPEAKER FOR INCLUDING ME IN
THIS DISCUSSION MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO GETTING
THIS DONE RIGHT. THIS BILL JUST
SECURES THE FUNDS AND NOW THE
REAL WORK BEGINS OF ACTUALLY
BUILDING OUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND I ARE COMMITTED TO DOING
WHAT IT TAKES TO ENSURE THE
EQUITABLE BROADBAND ACCESS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS LET'S GET THIS
DONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISDIAGNOSIS CUNNINGHAM YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS THIS IS A BIG DEAL
AYE AYES AYE I SHARE THE
SENTIMENT OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
HEALDSBURG SANTA ROSA- AND I'M
I'M RISING IN SUPPORT THIS IS
THE MODERN EQUIVALENT IN MANY
WAYS OF RURAL ELECTRIFICATION
THAT WAS DONE. EIGHTY YEARS AGO.
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BACKBONE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
DIGITAL ECONOMY AND WE'RE
MAKING SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN THAT WE'RE GONNA SERVE
PEOPLE THAT NEED THAT. AS MANY
PEOPLE POINT OUT SPEECHES I
JUST LIKE TO MAKE A POINT
BECAUSE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT THIS CAN'T BE A ONE
TIME THING. THERE HAS TO BE
COMMITMENT ONGOING. BOTH PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE MONEY. TO BEAT
REPAIRING AND MAINTAINING THE
TO EVERY YEAR WILDFIRES BURN.
MILES AND MILES OF FIBER OPTIC
CABLE EVERY YEAR. IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT HAS TO BE
REPLACED AT SIGNIFICANT
EXPENSE. AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS BILL REALLY. FULLY
CONTEMPLATES THE OPERATION
MAINTENANCE COSTS I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE CLEAN UP WORK
WE NEED TO FUTURE YEARS BUT
DON'T LET THAT DETER YOU.
PLEASE FROM VOTING FOR THIS
BECAUSE VERY IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM MR COOLEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES
THIS IS VITAL TO THE ECONOMIC
WELL BEING OF OUR STATE A
QUARTER CENTURY AGO RANCHO
COROVA SAW AN AIRFORCE BASE
CLOSE BUT THE GREAT THING ABOUT
THAT AIRFORCE BASE AND ACTUALLY
HAD FIBER OPTICS RIGHTED WITH
HEART. WELL WE HAD TWO BASES
CLOSE THE REGION THE FIRST ONE
TO SURPASSES FORMER JOB BASED
WAS RANCHO CORDOVA WHERE
THERE'S NOW MORE COMMERCIAL
OFFICE SPACE IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO SO THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE SCHOOL
KIDS OUT THERE BUT ACTUALLY IS
A FOUNDATION FOR OUR STATE'S
ENTIRE ECONOMIC FUTURE. URGENT
I WILL. THANKS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I DO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY
SIX I JUST KNOW THAT- WANNA
MAKE COMMENT THAT WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE COMMISSION WILL
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE
TO ENSURE THAT RATES WILL BE
AFFORDABLE AND THAT THAT THERE
IS PARITY BETWEEN GOVERNMENT
OWNED NETWORKS AND THE PRIVATE
CARRIERS TO ENSURE THAT EACH
ARE REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE SAME
RULES AND REGULATIONS SO WE
HAVE APPROPRIATE COMPETITION
AND THAT THE BILL EXPLICITLY
REQUIRES THAT SERVICES WILL BE
ACCURATELY. AND RAPIDLY
DEPLOYED IN UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THIS IS
SOMETHING VERY VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL HELP EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US THANK YOU I.
SUPPORT MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
ONE IN A CALIFORNIA HOME STILL
DO NOT HAVE INTERNET ACCESS AND
SMALL TOWNS RULE COULD RURAL
AREAS IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IS EVEN HIGHER NUMBER OF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHO
REMAIN DISCONNECTED UNDER
CURRENT STANDARDS. THE STATE'S
ESTIMATE TO FILL THE GAP IS CUT
CUT IN CONNECTIVITY IS SIX
POINT NINE BILLION UNDER
CURRENT TECHNOLOGY STANDARDS.
AND THE FCC IS CONSIDERING
RAISING THEM AS WE SPEAK. THERE
ARE IN FACT PRODUCTIVITY
PROBLEMS AND URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
TECHNOLOGY STATE. THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE IT
GLARINGLY CLEAR THAT WHILE
CONNECTIVITY IS CRITICAL IN
NORMAL TIMES IT CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH IN TIMES OF EMERGENCY.
OVER THE PAST SIXTEEN MONTHS
TOO MANY OF OUR PEOPLE WENT
WITHOUT CONNECTIONS TO
TELEHEALTH. DISTANCE LEARNING
AND THE DIGITAL ECONOMY THE
MAKES MAKE OTHERS LIVES
MOURNERS NORMAL. IN THE END
DURING THE STATE'S INCREASINGLY
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES AND OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS AND ACTIVITY
CAN MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIFE AND DEATH. MEMBERS I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR OVER A
DECADE STARTING AS MAYOR OF THE
SMALL TOWN OF WINTERS TO FIX.
TO FIX FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE ELECT A VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND AND THEY TEND TO BE
THOSE MOST IN NEED. A GREAT
MANY OF US HERE ON THIS FLOOR
ARE WORKING ON DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THIS FIGHT. ANY OF
YOU JOIN ME AS CO AUTHORS AS A
B. FOURTEEN THE POLICY CHAMPION
THE COMPANION. TO THIS
GENERATIONAL BUDGET INVESTMENT.
TO GATHER WE'VE BUILT THE
MOMENT MOMENTOUS TAKES A LOOK
SEE THIS YEAR NOW IS THE TIME
FOR US TO SEIZE THE MOMENT AND
BRING ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
FOR THEIR WORK. THEIR HEALTH
AND THE QUALITY OF LIFE. I
PASSIONATELY AND I MEAN
PASSIONTELY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY MS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF OUR
SB ONE FIFTY SIX I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THOSE THAT HAVE
ENGAGED I AND COUNTLESS HOURS
OF WORK TO MAKE THIS A REALITY
I WOULD LIKE TO ESPECIALLY
CONGRATULATE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WENT FROM WINTERS ON HER
COUNTLESS AND COUNTLESS HOURS.
AND I OF WORK IN THE ADVOCATING
FOR PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS AND SEEN HER LABOR OF
LOVE COME TO FRUITION AS A
TEACHER I THANK YOU ALL ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THE STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND I URGE EIGHT
AND I VOTE ON. SB ONE FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU MEASURE VIA MISTER
GIBSON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY SIX
DEALER BROADBAND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
CONVERSATIONS I WANT TO THANK
THE SPEAKER OUR OUR SPEAKER-
ALSO HIS ENTIRE STAFF OF MY
BILLS ON THE CALLS ARE WORKING
WITH AND SO MANY OTHERS MY
COLLEAGUES IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO. PROVIDE INPUT IN TERMS OF
HOW TO GET THIS BROADBAND BILL-
TRAILER BILL RIGHT MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW THAT I AUTHORED
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE DEALING WITH-
CONNECTIVITY DELIVERED PUBLIC
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING. THE THIS
TRAILER BILL IS NOT A PERFECT
BILL IT WOULD BE PERFECT IF WE
INCLUDE ABA NOT FORGET THOSE
WHO LIVE IN PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING. THIS WEEKEND OR LAST
WEEKEND I HAD OPPORTUNITY TO
WALK OF FOR- PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING IN MY DISTRICT- SOME OF
THOSE OF NICKERSON GARDENS.
JORDAN DOWNS IMPERIAL COURTS
AND GUNS ACT BILLETS. THOSE
PARTICULAR OF HOUSES WAS BUILT
IN A TIME WHERE THEY HAVE
CENTER BLOCK WALLS WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN WELL I'M GLAD YOU
ASKED YOU CAN'T PENETRATE YOU
CAN'T EVEN PUT A PICTURE ON THE
WALL WITH A NAIL BECAUSE THE
WALLS ARE MADE OUT OF CONCRETE.
SO TO HAVE ANY KIND OF SIGNALS
COME IN THERE'S IMPOSSIBLE AND
SO THERE WAS KIDS WHO WE TALK
ABOUT DISTANCE LEARNING BUT
THERE WAS NO DISTANCE LEARNING
THAN A PROJECTS I'M SORRY WILL
CALL THE PROJECTS ANYMORE THEY
CALL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS LET
ME BE POLITICALLY CORRECT. KIDS
WE'RE NOT DOING ANY DISTANCE
LEARNING BECAUSE THEY HAD NO
ABILITY TO DO IT. BECAUSE THEY
HAD NO INTERNET THERE WAS NO
THERE WAS NO CONNECTIVE ITTY TO
THE INTERNET. ACCESS WHATSOEVER
IN THOSE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
IN WHICH I REPRESENT. AND
THAT'S THE SAME FOR THOSE EAST
LOS ANGELES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA 40% OF CALIFORNIANS
DUNCAN IS NOT CONNECTED. SO
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT TO
CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A CALIFORNIA THAT IS
CONNECTED. TO THE PRIVILEGE AND
ONE THAT IS NOT CONNECTED AND
DISENFRANCHISED. AND THAT'S THE
PROBLEM THAT WE CAN NOT FORGET
ABOUT THE LEAST OF THESE. I
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE
REPRESENT THE SIX FORCE
DISAGREES THAT A CALIFORNIA.
AND I WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT
MARKED. A CONSTITUENCIES ARE
PART OF THE LEAST OF THESE THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. SO WE
LABOR OVER THE WEEKEND TO TRY
TO HAMMER OUT THE LANGUAGE I
THINK WE FELL A LITTLE SHORT.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO YES WE
TALK ABOUT LOW INCOME RESIDENTS.
BUT LOW INCOME RESIDENTS BUT
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN PUBLIC
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING. I NEED TO
MAKE SURE I CANNOT STAY ON THIS
FLOOR AND REPRESENTS MY
COMMUNITY ABOUT ALL RAISE THEIR
VOICES. THERE WERE KIDS WILL
FOLLOW ME. ON LAST WEEKEND
SATURDAY WHERE THEY WOULD
NORMALLY BE PLAYING WITH OTHER
KIDS THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
THEY WERE WITH ME PASSED OUT
LITERATURE ABOUT FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO HAVE. CONNECTIVITY'S YOU TO
BROADBAND SERVICE AND WE DO OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ON JUST IF IN
FACT WE DON'T MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT LEFT
OUT THEY HAVE TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE NOT DOING
ITS JOB I'M NOT DOING MY JOB IF
I DON'T RAISE MY VOICE TO MY
MICROPHONE. TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THOSE PEOPLE THE PEOPLE THAT
I STILL DON'T SHOW TO GAVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
SO I REYES THAT BOYS AND REYES
A CONSCIOUS LEVEL WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU OUR WORK IS
STILL. IS NOT DONE YET WE STILL
HAVE TO HAMMER OUT THE WORK AND
I WOULD THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
COACHELLA FOCUS ON BEING A DRUM
MAJOR FOR JUSTICE I'M TO MAKING
SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH WE
PASSAGE TRAILER BILL TODAY.
THAT THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE
DONE IN THIS SPACE I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO BECAUSE IT SUPPORTS
THE RULE COMMUNITIES. IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR PEOPLE
TO DRIVE TEN MILES FROM WHERE
THEY LIVE IN A RURAL COMMUNITY
TO TRY TO FIND SOME
CONNECTIVITY THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME WE LIVE IN THE
FITNESS WORLD ACCOUNT ACADEMY.
AND WE HAVE TO GET A RIGHT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE POLICIES
THAT WE PUT FORTH ON THIS FLOOR
INCLUDES THE LEAST. OF THESE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THEY
MUST GIVE. MISS WALDRON. YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS CLEARLY
UNDERSERVED AS FAR AS BROADBAND
GOES MY DISTRICT. IS 85% WORLD
THERE IS NO INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE THERE MIGHT BE A TOWER UP
ON PALOMAR MOUNTAIN. AND WHEN
THERE'S ICE THERE'S NO SERVICE
WHEN THERE'S- LEAVES THE GIRL
IN FRONT THERE'S NO SERVICE YOU
CAN BARELY GET FIVE M. PBS OF
ANY DOWNLOAD ANYWAY SO MOST OF
MY DISTRICT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM. IN GETTING ACCESS TO
BROADBAND SO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS DEFINITELY
AFFECTED AND SHOULD NOT BE LEFT
OUT. BUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO LOOK
FORWARD AS THIS BILL MOVES IS
THAT THIS IS NOT. COMPLETE I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
WORK DONE ESPECIALLY IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE DIRECTLY REQUIRE
THAT THE THREE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION. THAT IS BEING DEPLOYED
IN UNSERVED AREAS DEFINED AS
TWENTY FIVE M. B. PS DOWN
STREAMING TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
FUNDS. ARE NOT USED TO OVER
BUILD WITH THERE'S EXISTING
FACILITIES. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CLEAR DEFINITION OF RURAL AND
URBAN TO ENSURE FAIRNESS. AND
TO STREAMLINE PERMITS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW TO GET
THIS DONE SO. THERE'S STILL
SOME WORK TO BE DONE BUT I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS AND WE
NEED TO GET MOVING ON IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MR
RAHMAN'S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN IT THANK
YOU FOR ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING- THE MUCH NEEDED
BROADBAND ACCESS TO ALL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT MENTIONED THAT
DURING COAL THAT EXPOSE A LOT
OF THINGS HOWEVER IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IT'S- AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN PLAGUING US FOR
MANY MANY YEARS- BEING LEFT OUT
OF THE PROCESS. SO I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WERE
INCLUDING IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THE INCLUSION OF
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. BROADBAND ACCESS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE IS AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES I WANT
TO THANK THEM MY COLLEAGUES IN
THIS BODY FOR BEING ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD TO INCLUDE THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. IN PART OF
THAT PROCESS AND MAKING SURE
THEY'LL HAVE A VOICE WITH THE
OPEN ACCESS TO MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND NETWORK LOCATIONS
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT BROADBAND FOR ALL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LET'S
REMEMBER THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR
MANY YEARS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION THROUGH THIS BODY
HERE TODAY WITH THE DIVERSITY
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE FIRST TIME
WE'RE INCLUDING THEM IN
IMPORTANT BILLS LIKE THIS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THAT
BROADBAND ACCESS SO EDUCATION
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
TIMES OF EMERGENCY THERE'S
ACCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE RESPONDING IN TIMES OF
NEED. I WANT TO THANK THIS BODY
I WANT FONG THANK THE AUTHORS
AND DOES IT WORKED ON IT FOR
INCLUDING THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY RESTAURANTS
MR LEVINE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE FIFTY SIX THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. IS A THREE YEAR SIX
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
BROADBAND. AND IT'S THE LARGEST
PUBLIC INVESTMENT TO ELIMINATE
CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL DIVIDE. IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. THE
PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN US THAT JUST
AS CLEAN WATER SAFE STREETS
BRIDGES AND ROADS. AND RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY IS AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
ACCESS TO RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
IS FUNDAMENTAL TO THE FUTURE.
SUCCESS OF CALIFORNIA FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. I SHARE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW WE MEASURE
THE SUCCESS OF THIS AMBITIOUS
ENDEAVOR. WILL WE GET THIS
RIGHT. IN MEASURING SUCCESS HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT THERE IS
APPROPRIATE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THOSE WE WILL AND TRUST TO
BUILD CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE MILE
TO EVERY COMMUNITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HOW DO WE MEASURE
SUCCESS TO ENSURE THAT URBAN
SUBURBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
ARE TREATED EQUITABLY HOW DO
YOU MEASURE SUCCESS AND HOW DO
WE MEASURE CLOSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. HOW DO WE MEASURE IF
THERE'S A BIG INVESTMENT IN
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
ACHIEVED ITS NOBLE GOALS. OR
FELL VICTIM TO HIGH
EXPECTATIONS BUT AN EVEN OR
UNCLEAR OUTCOMES. THIS
INVESTMENT IS A METAPHOR FOR
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROCESS. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET RIGHT. AND IT'S
OKAY TO TAKE THE TIME NECESSARY
TO ROUTE RID VISIT THIS AND
OTHER INVESTMENTS TO DO SO
THESE ARE GENERATIONAL
INVESTMENTS AND WE SHOULD NOT
LOOK BACK AND WONDER WHETHER
THE OUTCOMES MATCH THE INTENDED
GOALS OR WHETHER WE SQUANDERED
THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LEVINE MR
SANTIAGO. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THANK ALL OUR COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND
PARTICIPATION IN GETTING THIS
DONE THE BUDGET CHAIR- WHO IS
THE CENTER OF THE PROCESS AND-
ALSO- TO THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE BECAUSE WHEN WE BEGAN THE
YEAR. HE TALKED ABOUT THE YOUR
BROADBAND AND HERE WE ARE AT
THE AT THE CULMINATION OF THE
BUDGET. IMPLEMENTING A GAME
CHANGING INITIATIVES IN THIS IN
THIS BILL. N. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT INFORMATION IN THE
DEMOCRATIZING OF INFORMATION
THIS REALLY WILL BE A GAME
CHANGER ALLOWS THAT TO HAPPEN
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES FROM A COST POINT
PERSPECTIVE TO AN ACCESS
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THIS
CHANGES OUR LIVES IN MORE WAYS
THAN WE CAN IMAGINE FROM THE
ONSET. AND THIS PANDEMIC TAUGHT
US. PART OF WHAT WAS NEEDED
WHEN WE SAW LITTLE KIDS IN
FRONT AND FRONT OF A- A PART OF
A FAST FOOD RESTAURANT. TRYING
TO GAIN ACCESS BUT ALSO TAUGHT
US- IT ALSO TAUGHT US THAT WE
CAN DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY I CAN
NEIGHBORHOODS I REPRESENT FOR
TELEHEALTH BECAME MORE
IMPORTANT. I TEASE WHERE
EDUCATION BECAME. WHAT WELL
IMPORTANT TO STAND THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S CONNECTION
WHAT WE SAW THE DIGITAL VIDE.
CRASH ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I
DON'T THINK WE CAN
UNDERESTIMATE HOW IMPORTANT IS
THIS I DO AGREE THAT WE'VE GOT
TO GET THIS RIGHT. BUT THIS IS
THIS WILL BE A GAME CHANGER FOR
ALLOWING US TO HAVE THAT MIDDLE
MILE FROM ALLOWING US TO HAVE
THOSE LAST POINTS OF CONNECTION
AND ALLOWING US TO BE ABLE TO.
THE FINALLY HAVE BROADBAND FOR
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
THINK THIS HOUSE. I THINK I
SPEAK AGAIN FOR HELPING US TO
PUT THIS TOGETHER BECAUSE THIS
WILL BE THAT GAME CHANGER WE'LL
LOOK BACK YEARS FROM NOW AND
UNDERSTAND WHY ALL CALIFORNIA
HAS. BROADBAND INTERNET PUT OUT
WILL BE MUCH BETTER. I RESPECT
THAT AND I BOTH. THANK OF A
SANTIAGO SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. FEDERAL ATTACK
ABOUT I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MISTER
CHALLENGE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SIXTY THREE AND SEVENTY
SEVEN TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM TO TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS AB ONE SIXTY FOUR AB
ONE THIRTY ONE AB ONE THIRTY
TWO AB ONE THIRTY FIVE AB ONE
FORTY AB ONE FORTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER FLORIDA. WE WILL
HOLD NELSON SENT US FOR WILL
CALL VOTE MR FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MISTER CHOW MOVES AND MR TANG
SECONDS ON THE RULES SUSPENSION
MEMBERSHIPS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. PURPLE OF THE ROLE MR
CHOW IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN MISTER LOOR IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. MISTER CHOW IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. A MISTER FLOOR
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ON THE
PROCEDURE OVER. WELL CULTURAL
TIES THAT I FIFTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHTEEN. THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MISTER CHANG WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING TO TAKE
UP SOME OF THE AB USE AT THIS
TIME. THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE. AB. ONE SIX FOUR.
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY FOUR
THE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING ALKYLATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET MAKING OF
OPERATION ARE FOR SIGNIFICANT
NEW A BUDGET BILL MISTER KING
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE SIXTY FOUR IS
OUR BUDGET BILL JUNIOR CONTAINS
A FEW MINOR CHANGES TO. AMEND
OUR BUDGET CONFORM TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION BUDGET TO REFLECT THE
CHILD CARE RATE REFLECT LEVELS
REFLECTED IN THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FOR THE BILL IN AB
ONE THIRTY ONE ADJUST THE
BUDGET BILL TO REFLECT THE
FUNDING GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES
FOR THE BROADBAND PROJECT AS
ARTICULATED IN THE- BROADBAND
TRAILER BILL SB ONE FIFTY SIX
BUT WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THE- PAGE TEN MR FONG. I
THINK THIS IS BIGGER. A MEMBERS
THIS IS OUR FOURTH BUDGET
VERSION AND FIVE WEEKS. THE
PROBLEM WITH SEQUELS THE STORY
IS THE SAME AND THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH MARKETING TO MAKE IT
BETTER. THIS BUDGET IS COMING
TOGETHER STILL IN PIECES
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S. STILL
RUSHED CONTINUES TO BE ON THIS.
AS BEING DRY OT BY MINUTE
DEALS M. WE KNOW. THERE WILL BE
TO COME. MA'AM WE MADE IT TO
ROCKY FOR OF THE BUDGET C. BUT
WE NOW FIVE GET MY BETTER I
URGE A NO VOTE. DAMOS FONG
SEEING THEIR- OTHER DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ADDED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY NINE KNOWS FOR SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
ONE CHILD CARE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY ONE BY
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACCORDING TO CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IN MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FORCE TAKE A
COMMUNITY PRIVILEGE THE BUDGET.
MISTER KING. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE THIRTY ONE IS
OUR EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION.
TRAILER BILL THIS IS A
COMPANION TO OUR S. B. ONE
THIRTY UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN BILL. THE BILL
MAKES SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN
REALLY IS OVER A DECADE'S WORTH
OF ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF MANY
OF THE LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS
HERE. IN IN THE ROOM BEEN
FIGHTING FOR EXPANDED CHILD
CARE SLOTS FOR RATE REFORM SO
THAT MANY OF THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WHO GET PAID VERY LOW
WAGES. CAN NOW HAVE A LIVING
WAGE WHILE THEY'RE TAKING CARE
OF OUR CHILDREN WE KNOW HOW
CRITICAL IT IS TO HAVE
CONSISTENT AND AFFORDABLE CHILD
CARE BECAUSE IF YOU CAN'T. HAVE
CHILD CARE YOU CAN'T GO TO WORK
LIKE MY FAMILY AND MANY SO MANY
OTHER FAMILIES IF WE DON'T HAVE
CHILD CARE. MANY OF US COULD BE
HERE TODAY. THIS EXPANDS OUR
CHILD CARE SLOTS BEGINNING THIS
YEAR BY A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND WITH ADDING TWENTY
THOUSAND A YEAR. WE HAVE A RATE
REFORM PACKAGE THAT FUNDS ALL
OUR CHILD CARE PROGRAMS AT THE
REGIONAL RATE FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER INCREASES. ALL THE
PROVIDER LEVELS TO THE LATEST
RATE SURVEY. WAYS FAMILY FEES
BY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IT ALSO
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR NEW OR IMPROVED
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THIS IS
FOR THE NON ELLIE A FACILITIES
ALL THE NONPROFIT. PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PROVIDERS WITHOUT I
JUST ONE OF THE KNOWLEDGE
SOMEBODY OF THE LEGISLATORS
HERE WHO HAD A HUGE PART IN
MAKING THIS A REALITY
PARTICULAR ARE. ARE CHAIR OF A
BUDGET SUB TO AS WELL AS THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS REALLY MADE
THIS AN ONGOING PRIORITY OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
I THOUGHT IT AB ONE THIRTY ONE.
MISTER FONG YOUR RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU MISTER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THIRTY ONE
FROM PROVIDING EDUCATION
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
ESSENTIALS TO CHILDREN THESE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT IN SUPPORTING
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
I'M HOPEFUL THE TRANSFER OF
THESE PROGRAMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE. EARLY
CHILDCARE. AND THAT WILL BE A
BETTER COURT AND AT THAT THERE
WILL ALSO BE BETTER
COORDINATION AMONG VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS PROVIDING THESE
NEEDED SERVICES. THIS BILL
PROVIDES TWO YEARS OF FUNDING
USING ONE TIME FUNDS FOR MORE
CHILD CARE OPENINGS BUT FACES.
UNCERTAIN FUNDING IN THE FUTURE
IN THE FUTURE I WOULD CAUTION
THAT THIS BILL USES THE ONE
TIME FUNDS A GREAT NEW AND
ONGOING OBLIGATIONS. YOU MUST
COMMIT TO SUSTAIN FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN TO PROVIDE THEM THE
CERTAINTY THEY NEED THE Y.
URGENT AND I VOTE ON AB ONE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MR FONG
MR GRAYSON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE THIRTY ONE. AND A EARLY
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS
IMPERATIVE IT'S VITAL TO A
HEALTHY FUTURE. AND I APPLAUD
ALL THAT HAVE WORKED SO HARD.
TO EXPAND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TO ALL BUT IN DOING
SO WE HAVE CREATED A TWO TIER
SYSTEM THAT HAS. RESULTED IN
DOUBLE STANDARDS. MOVING
FORWARD BY PUTTING THIS ALL
UNDER A- A SINGLE RATE- OR-
REIMBURSEMENT RATE- IT IS IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. HOWEVER
THERE ARE OTHER AREAS THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED AND I ASK FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP MOVING INTO
THE- INTO THE FUTURE. ON
ADDRESSING THE DESPAIR
DISPARITIES THAT COMES TO THIS
TWO TIER SYSTEM. AND AND- THE
DOUBLE STANDARD THAT EXISTS
FROM IT. I DO RISE IN SUPPORT
AND ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK
MISS GRAYSON MS GARCIA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THIRTY ONE BEFORE. ANY OF US
GOT HERE THE LIMITS CAUCUS HAS
BEEN CHAMPIONING THE SPACE. WE
KNOW THAT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
THIS I FEEL WAS UNDERPAID AND
UNDERVALUED MOSTLY
PREDOMINATELY WOMEN WHEN A
WOMAN OF COLOR FIELD. TAKING
CARE OF OUR MOST PRECIOUS.
ASSETS AND FUTURE OF THEIR
CHILDREN ARE EARLY ON AND THERE
YEARS AND WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING
TO INCREASE RATES WILL INCREASE
OF FIGHTING TO INCREASE LOTS
FOR OVER A DECADE. AND SO
EXCITING THAT TODAY WE ARE
FINALLY SEEING THAT RATE
INCREASE EVERYTHING ADDITIONAL
SLOTS. BUT LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE BAY AREA SAID THERE'S
MORE WORK TO BE DONE INTO THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS COMMITTED TO
ENSURE WE VALUE THESE CARE
WORKERS WHAT I'LL BE DOING THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF. HELPING TO
MOLD OUR CHILDREN TO OUR FUTURE
LEADERS I INTO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO INCLUDE MORE
FAMILIES IN THIS SPACE. I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE CHAMPIONS IN
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATE IN THE SPACE WE NOT
ONLY HAVE NEW SLOTS AND RATE
REFORM WE ARE ALSO WAITING
FAMILY FEES THANKS TO THE
LEADERS OF OUR QUALITY
CONTAMINATED YOU KNOW. WE ARE
DOING ADMINISTRATIVE REFORM
THANKS OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
FULLER TEN WE ARE MMHM. I DO
KNOW A LOT MORE DOING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SAID THIS IS
A COLLECTIVE EFFORT IS AN
EFFORT THAT. IS BIPARTISAN THAT
IS BOTH ABOUT THE MEN AND THE
WOMEN IN THIS. BODY AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
WITH ALL OF YOU TO CONTINUE TO
LIVE UP THIS WORKFORCE WE TALK
ABOUT GETTING ACK TO WORK- AND
WE CANNOT GET BACK TO WORK AND
WE DON'T GET THIS RIGHT AND SO
WE KNOW THAT. AS WE DO THAT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY NOT JUST
TODAY BUT IN FUTURE YEARS WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
THE SPACE. AND FINALLY I DO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
LEADERSHIP OVER SPEAKER WHO-
BEFORE YOU CAME HERE THAT A LOT
OF WORK IN THIS SPACE AND HAS
BEEN AN ADVOCATE IN THE SPACES
WHILE AND WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO BE HERE. THEY LISTEN WITH
THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR SPEAKER
AND I APPROACHED HIM IN THE
OTHER HOUSE AND I BUDGET CHAIRS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA MISS. THEIR YOUR-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THIRTY ONE- THIS PAST YEAR WE
HAVE LOST SO MANY PROVIDERS-
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
WE'VE LOST WORK FORCE WE'VE
LOST CHILD CARE SLOTS. AND I
TOO AM ONE OF THOSE LEGISLATORS
THAT HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
EXPANDED ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
AND PRESCHOOL FOR OVER A
DECADE. I'M REALLY EXCITED TO
SUPPORT THIS. TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS. IS AMAZING- IT
I APPLAUD WHAT WE'RE DOING I DO
HAVE ONE CONCERN THOUGH BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT DONE YET. THERE IS NO
MONEY IN THIS BUDGET.
ADDITIONAL MONEY OR THE MONEY
THAT WE NEED FOR THE WORK
FORCE. A TRADITIONAL- RATIO AND
A CHILD CARE SETTING IS ONE TO
SIX OR ONE TO TWELVE. WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO. TO FILL TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SLOTS. WE'RE
GONNA NEED THOUSANDS OF NEW
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. AND NOT
REQUIRES DEVELOPING OUR
WORKFORCE SO WE'RE NOT DONE. WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT MOVING
FORWARD. I'M BUT I DO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MR MCCARTY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT TRAILER
BILLS THAT WERE VOTING ON
PIECES OF THE BUDGET- IS
CERTAINLY A TOP PRIORITY FOR US
DURING THE- PANDEMIC AND
FRANKLY EVERY YEAR. WE CAN'T
HAVE A THRIVING ECONOMY WE
CANNOT- PEOPLE GOING TO WORK.
UNLESS WE HAVE. A FUNCTIONING
CHILD CARE SYSTEMS AND WE LOOK
ABOUT OUR ECONOMIC FUTURE IF
YOU WANT TO ADDRESS THE THAT
SHE MEANT GAP.
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE EVERY
ECONOMIST SAYS ONE THING.
INVEST MORE IN OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS WILL THIS DOES JUST
THAT AS PART OF AN OVERALL
PUZZLE. AS OUR BUDGET SHARE
NOTED. THIS IS THE EARLY
EDUCATION BUDGET THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DREAMING ABOUT FOR
FRANKLY DECADES OVER SIX POINT
FIVE. BILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING SUPPORT TO EXPAND
ACCESS FOR CHILD. RICKLY THE
BIGGEST PIECE THE PIECE WHILE
WE HELD UP THE BUDGET LAST TWO
WEEKS IS TO MAKE SURE WE PAY
PROPER RATES. FOR ALL OF THESE
CENTER BASED IN FAMILY BASED
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE. AND TO
MAKE SURE THEY PAY THEIR
WORKERS LIVING WAGES. SO WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN THIS MEANS THAT
CURRENTLY THERE ARE FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THE
WAITING LIST TO GET CHILD CARE.
AT THIS BUDGET IS IMPLEMENTED
WITH THE SLOTS OF THEIR
BUDGETARY LIT TWO. HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND NOW TWENTY
THOUSAND MORE FOR THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. THE WAITING LIST FOR
FAMILIES WILL BE CUT IN HALF.
SO THOSE FAMILIES CAN GO BACK
TO WORK GO TO SCHOOL. AND BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES. AS FAR AS- OVERALL
PUBLICLY FUNDED SLOTS FOR CHILD
CARE STATE PRESCHOOL NTK OVER
HALF A MILLION. AGAIN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WE WANT ALL
THESE ARE OUR NUMBERS IN
BILLIONS OF MILLIONS BUT THINK
ABOUT PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WILL NOT HAVE
FREE. PUBLICLY FUNDED. EARLY
CHILD EDUCATION FULL DAY
PROGRAMS TO HELP THEIR FAMILIES
SIXTY. THIS IS A WIN WIN WIN
FOR CALIFORNIA AGAIN. TOP
PRIORITY FOR OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
BUT ALSO FOR THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS OF THIS IS AN ISSUE
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON. LEAD BE
OCCUPIERS SPEAKER OUR BUDGET
SHARE AND AGAIN OR LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS LED BY. OUR
CHAIRMAN FROM THE SOUTH L. A.
COUNTY THANK YOU FOR AT
EVERYBODY SUPPORT OF THIS.
THANK YOU MEASURE MCCARTY. SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE BUDGET ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. AB
ONE THIRTY TWO WITH A REFERENCE
TO FILE AB ONE THREE TWO
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACTIVATING THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION A MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR STICK FOR
COMMUNITY ABILITY TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER K. THANK YOU BUT
SPEAKER AB ONE THIRTY TWO IS A
HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER BILL
LIKE SOMEBODY WITH OTHER
TRAILER BILL TO REALLY LAYS THE
FOUNDATION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
IN OUR STATE. FOR THE
FORTHCOMING FUTURE. THIS BILL
EXPANDS CAL GRANTS TO MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND. LOW INCOME
COMMUNICATIONS BY ELIMINATING.
THESE BARRIERS TO THE- PROGRAM.
EXPANDS REFORMS ARE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. IT DIRECTS
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA TO
REDUCE THE OUT OF STATE
ENROLLMENT DOWN 218% AT UCLA UC
BERKELEY UC SAN DIEGO. IT ALSO
EXPANDS OUR STATE COLLEGE
SAVINGS PROGRAM. TIRES THE
DEFERRALS FOR ALL THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT WERE CREATED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. INCREASE A
NEW REQUIREMENT THAT HIGH
SCHOOLS MUST ENSURE THAT
SENIORS. FILL OUT FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS THIS. TRAILER BILL
CONTINUES ALL THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO MAKE SURE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION AFFORDABLE FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A RESPECT
RESTAURANT ADULT ON AB ONE
THIRTY TWO. THINGS CHANGE MR
FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THERE'S NO DOUBT HIGHER
EDUCATION PROVIDES A GATEWAY TO
SUCCESS THIS BILL INCLUDES
NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN OUR UC
AND CSU SYSTEMS AND FINALLY
PAYS ALCHEMY COLLEGE DEFERRALS.
OUR STATE COLLEGES ARE GEARING
UP FOR A MONUMENTAL RETURN TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AND MORE
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS IS GREATLY
NEEDED WE SHOULD BE EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUCCESS BUT
THIS BILL. WOULD RESTRICT
ATTENDANCE OPTIONS AND AGAIN
EXCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM
ACCESSING TOOLS THAT THEY COULD
USE TO HELP THEIR STUDENTS
UNFORTUNATELY I CANNOT SUPPORT.
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE OF THAT.
THANK YOU MR FONG WISH MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER. SPEAKER THIS AS OUR
BUDGET SHARE NUDE NOTED IS
AGAIN THIS IS A HISTORIC BUDGET
WE KEEP SAYING THIS IS THE
LARGEST INCREASE FOR ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY. FOR COLLEGE. IN
GENERATIONS FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU GO BACK HOME
AND TALK TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS
ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION WHAT
THEY TALK ABOUT. TWO THINGS HOW
COLLEGES TOO EXPENSIVE. HOW
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
GRADUATING WITH TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE THE
STUDENT DEBT. WELL THE OTHER
THING YOU HEAR IS HOW THEIR
NEIGHBOR THEIR LOVED ONE. HAS A
FOUR POINT FIVE GPA. IS APPLIED
TO THE UC. NEEDS TO GO TO
UNIVERSITY OREGON OR SOMEWHERE
ELSE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET
INTO OUR PUBLICLY FUNDED
COLLEGES. WE ARE TAXPAYERS AND
WE'RE SQUEEZING OUT
CALIFORNIANS. WELL NO MORE WE
ARE REDUCING THE NUMBER OF NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS SO MORE AND
MORE ACCESS FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES. AS FAR AS FINANCIAL
AID THE STUDENT DEBT CRISIS.
THIS THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS THE
WORK THAT ARE BUT OUR HIGHER ED
SHARE. FROM RIVERSIDE HAS BEEN
WORKING ON FOR MANY YEARS WITH
OUR BUDGETARY MYSELF. TO BRING
ABOUT A DEBT FREE COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS NOT.
SOMETHING THAT IS A- YOU KNOW
WAY OUT THERE IN THE FUTURE
THIS LAYS THE WORK TO MAKE
COLLEGE DEBT FREE IN CALIFORNIA
NOT FREE. DEBT FREE CELL BASED
UPON YOUR FAMILY INCOME. YOUR
EXISTING FINANCIAL AID YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO GRADUATE. WITHOUT
HAVING THIS MOUNTING STUDENT
DEBT AND WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE STUDENTS WORK THE
TRADITIONAL FIFTEEN HOURS A
WEEK TO PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
SO WITH THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
OF THAT ALLOW OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS TO
GET SUPPLEMENTAL FINANCIAL AID.
TO PAY FOR NON TUITION COSTS
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE THIS.
RISING STUDENT DEBT CRISIS AND
LASTLY FOR SO MANY STUDENTS ARE
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
THEY APPLY FOR THE CALTRAIN AS
WE KNOW.AND THEY GET IN A
LOTTERY ONLY ONE IN FOURTEEN
GET TO GET THE ELUSIVE CAL
GRANT A WORD WITH THIS WE'RE
GOING TO ELIMINATE THAT BARRIER
AND OPEN WIDE OPEN THE DOORS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. FOR
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT IS A
GAME CHANGER FOR ACCESS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IN OUR STATE
THAT WILL CHANGE LIVES SO THAT
WILL HAVE AN AUTOMATIC
ELIGIBILITY IF THEY HAVE THE
INCOME ELIGIBILITY. AND OF
COURSE THEY'RE QUALIFIED TO GO
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO THIS IS
THE FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE THAT
AGAIN WE'VE ALL BEEN WORKING
OUT. FOR OVER A DECADE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. DAMOS
MCCARTY MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I WAS VERY
CIRCUMSPECT BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE
VOTING ON MANY DIFFERENT BUDGET
ITEMS ONE BETTER THAN THE OTHER
AND SO I WAS CIRCUMSPECT ON
WHICH ONE I WAS GOING TO CHOOSE
TO SPEAK ON AND THIS WAS IT.
THIS IS I WANTED TO FIRST OF
ALL THANK THE BUDGET CHAIR AS
WELL AS THE BUDGETS- EDUCATION
SUB CHAIR- ON ON SUPPORTING AND
JOINING ON BOARD EARLY ON IN
THE CHILDREN'S SAVINGS ACCOUNT
PROGRAM WANTED TO ALSO THINK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION ON THE WONDERFUL
WORK THAT THEY DID. IN THE
COLLABORATION COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MOVE THIS FORWARD. FOLKS WE'RE
VOTING ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ITEMS THAT QUITE CANDIDLY ARE
WONDERFUL BUT THE REACTIVE WERE
ALWAYS FALLING BEHIND AND WE'RE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO CATCH UP.
WE HEAR ABOUT COMMENTS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT WE'RE LIVING
IN A CALIFORNIA TWO DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA'S OR ABOUT INVESTING
IN OUR YOUTH OR CONNECTING
RURAL AND POOR AREAS TO THE
REST OF THE STATE BECAUSE- OF
THE IN INADEQUACIES AND- THAT
THAT ARE. BROADBAND AND UTILITY
PROGRAMS HAVE. THE CHILDREN
SAVINGS ACCOUNT IS ONE PROGRAM
THAT IT'S NOT A REACTION. IT IS
ACTUALLY AN INVESTMENT TO THE
FUTURE. EVERY CHILD BORN IN
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO START
OUT WITH AN ACCOUNT. IN THEIR
SAVING IN IN THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN. BY THE TIME THEY'RE
IN FIRST GRADE IF THEY ARE FROM
A POOR SOCIOECONOMIC FAMILY.
THEY WILL GET AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING. AND BY
FIRST GRADE THEY WILL HAVE OVER
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THEIR
ACCOUNT WHICH FOR THE NEXT
TWELVE YEARS WILL GROW TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY
HAVE A MEANINGFUL AMOUNT APPLY
TOWARDS THEIR- CAREER ENHANCING
OPPORTUNITY MAY BE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING TECH TECHNICAL
TRAINING COLLEGE WHEREVER IT
MAY BE. IT'S PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
THAT ARE GIVING DIRECT
INVESTMENTS BACK INTO OUR YOUTH
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE A
CRITICAL THAT ARE GONNA MAKE A
CRITICAL DIFFERENCE. IN THE
FUTURE SO I DO APPRECIATE US
WORKING VERY HARD AND
COLLABORATIVELY THIS IS THIS IS
THE TREE THAT WE'RE PLANNING
TODAY SO THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION BENEFITS FROM THE
SHADE AND THE FRUITS THAT'S
GOING TO BE OFFERED BY THIS
TREE. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY AYEVOTE
AND AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION IN SUPPORTING
THE CALC ITS PROGRAM THAT WE
WORKED ON PUTTING IN THE BUDGET
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLERK WILL
FEDERAL. RESERVE IS AT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBER SHOWED A DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY NINE NO
SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. AB. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. HUMAN SERVICES.
COOKERY ASSEMBLY ROOM ONE
THIRTY FIVE BODY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO HUMAN
SERVICES MAKING A PROVISION
AFFORDS TAKE A COMMUNITY
PRIVILEGE THE BUDGET. MISTER K.
THANK YOU AB ONE THIRTY FIVES
ARE HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER
BILL. THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR
FOCUSES ON THE MOST VULNERABLE
IN THE LOWEST INCOME FAMILIES.
ALL THROUGHOUT OUR SATE. IT
ALLOWS FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS TO RUN
THROUGH OUR FRONT LINE COUNTY
OFFICES. GREW TO CULTURE AND
SHIPS. THE PRACTICE OF CAL
WORKS TO BE MUCH MORE. FAMILY
FOCUSED IN ORDER SO WE CAN DO A
BETTER JOB BREAKING THE CYCLE
OF POVERTY. WE DO A 20% RATE
INCREASE ON THE SS I SS P.
PROGRAM FOR INDIVIDUAL STARTING
IN JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. ELIMINATES THE 7% HOURS
REDUCTION IN OUR IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. PROGRAM
LOWERED THE AGE FOR VULNERABLE
SENIORS TO BE SERVED IN THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM FROM SIXTY FIVE TO
SIXTY. AND TAKES FIRST STEPS TO
EXPAND FOOD ACCESS FOR THOSE
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR OUR
BASIC. FOOD ASSISTANCE- BUT FOR
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. AGAIN
THESE FAMILIES ARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES HERE IN OUR
STATE WE SHOULD ALWAYS MEASURE
GOVERNMENT NOT BY WHAT WE DO
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE. THE MOST
MEANS IN OUR STATE BUT REALLY
BY THOSE WHO HAVE THE LEAST IN
WITHOUT A VERY PROUD TO.
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR- AYE
VOTE ON AB ONE THIRTY FIVE.
THEY WERE TECHNICIAN. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. ON I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE THIRTY
FIVE THIS BILL HAS TROUBLING
PROVISIONS THAT PENALIZES
COUNTIES AS THEY ATTEMPT TO
REACH AGREEMENTS AND DELIVERING
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THESE PENALTIES WILL NEGATIVELY
IMPACT FUNDING FOR OTHER
REALIGNMENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
COUNTIES ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE
SUCH AS SOCIAL SERVICES PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS. WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON EXPANDING CARE AND ACCESS TO
ONE WILL CALIFORNIANS WHO TRULY
NEED IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES NOT MANUFACTURING A
ONE SIDED DEAL AT THE EXPENSE
OF OTHER CRITICAL SERVICES. I
REGION OF UP. THEY WISH FONG MR
HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS
CHAIR O THE ASSEMBLY UTILITY
ENERGY COMMITTEE I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SB ONE THIRTY
FIVE WELL THIS IS A HUMAN
SERVICE TRAILER BILL IT ALSO
CONTAINS A PROGRAM THAT WILL
HELP CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
STATE PAY THEIR ELECTRIC AND
NATURAL GAS BILLS THAT HAVE
GONE UNPAID TO THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE COVERT NINETEEN.
THE DEBT PANDEMIC A SIMILAR
PROGRAM OF WATER AND WASTEWATER
BILLS IS INCLUDED IN S. B. AND
AB ONE FORTY EIGHT. THIS FIRST
IN THE NATION PROGRAM WILL HELP
PROVIDE FAST AND EFFICIENT
UTILITY BILL RELIEF TO HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS. I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY BILL
BUDGET HERE COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO SET UP THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN DOCTOR ARAMBULA. YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE TO
SUPPORT AB ONE THIRTY FIVE OR
HUMAN SERVICES OMNIBUS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. THE IRONY OF
LIVING ON THE BREAD BASKET OF
THE WORLD IS THAT THOSE WHO
WORKED SO DILIGENTLY TO PUT
FOOD ON ALL OF OUR TABLES. TOO
OFTEN FACE FOOD INSECURITY
THEMSELVES. THE SOLUTION FOR US
TO FIGHT HUNGER AT RECORD
LEVELS IN CALIFORNIA. IS FOR US
TO PROVIDE STRONG INVESTMENTS
INTO OUR EMERGENCY FOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS BUDGET
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT%
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT FOOD FOR
ALL AND ALSO TO SUPPORT OUR
INDISPENSABLE FOOD BANKS AND
ALLOW US AS THE STATE TO. BE
PREPARED WITH DISASTER
RESILIENCY FOR THE FUTURE. IT
ALSO SUPPORTS OUR SENIORS BY
INCREASING CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. FURTHER
THIS BUDGET PROTECTS OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA BY. EXPANDING AND
ENHANCING OUR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES ACT. IT ADDITIONALLY
OFFERS HOUSING STABILITY FOR
OLDER ADULTS AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS BY SUPPORTING THE
LAUDABLE HOME SAFE PROGRAM. AND
THIS BILL MAKES CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS AND CHANGES TO HELP
US TO MODERNIZE THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM SO THAT IT CAN BE A
REAL TRAUMA INFORMED SUPPORT TO
PARENTS AND THE CHILDREN. THIS
POWERFUL PROGRAM CAN BREAK THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY SO THAT THESE
PARENTS AND CHILDREN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. THE HUMAN
SERVICES INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
IN OUR PLAN REFLECT NOT ONLY
THE CARE SUPPORT AND SERVICES
THAT PEOPLE NEED TODAY BUT THE
CALIFORNIA THAT WE ALL WANT FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES.
AND THE POST PANDEMIC FUTURE
THAT IS BEAMING WITH
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL AND THAT IS
FUELED BY EQUITY. I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE THE COUNTIES THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE PUBLIC WHO WE
ALL SERVE. I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR REGULAR
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRABLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
FIFTY SIX KNOWS TEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT. THIS
IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY AB ONE
FORTY. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR STICK FOR
CAMILLE COOPER REALLY TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE FORTY
IT'S OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. TRAILER BILL THIS
BILL PROVIDES ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OF THE NEXT TWO
YEARS FOR MORE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING FOR OUR CITIES OR
COUNTIES ARE CONTINUES CARE.
AND ADDS GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY. ALL THEM WITH
OUR HOMELESS COORDINATING
COUNCIL HAVING THE ACTUAL
ABILITY TO DISCUSS METRICS. TO
ENSURE THE PERFORMANCE IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING. IN TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DOING A MUCH
BETTER JOB. DELIVERING AND
BUILDING TEMPORARY SHELTER
PERMANENT SHELTER AS WELL AS
DELIVERING THE SERVICES THAT WE
KNOW WE NEED. TO GET PEOPLE OFF
OUR STREETS. THIS BILL ALSO
APPROPRIATE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE HAVE SO MANY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS THAT ARE
SHOVEL READY AND READY TO GO.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WILL HELP GET THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
OUT IN BUILT AS WE SPEAK ARE
DESPERATELY. NEEDED TIME FOR
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE FORTY. PAGE TEN MR
FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE FORTY HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
ARE CRISES THAT REQUIRE
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS HAVE BEEN IGNORED
AND LEFT TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES ON THEIR OWN SO THE NEW
SET ASIDE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
INFILL GRANTS IT'S A GREAT
RELIEF AND WHAT DO A LOT TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE INDEED PLEADING
FOR HELP IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS ON OUR STREETS.
WITH THESE NEEDED RESOURCES
THERE MUST BE ACCOUNTABILITY
REAL METRICS AND TRANSPARENCY
TO ENSURE THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED EFFECTIVELY AND I
COMMEND OUR BUDGET CHAIR FOR
HIS WORK IN THIS ISSUE EACH
COMMUNITY IS UNIQUE SOLUTIONS
MUST COME FROM LOCAL OFFICIALS
IN PARTNERSHIP AND
COLLABORATION WITH OUR LOCAL
NONPROFITS AND THOSE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. THEY COULD USE
MORE HELP FROM SACRAMENTO WITH
MORE RECTORY STREAMLINING AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE CONTINUOUSLY
WORKED ON BUT AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR FONG MS
QUICK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FORTY RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING MANY OF YOU HAVE
SEEN ME RISE NUMEROUS TIMES TO
SPEAK ABOUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THE CRISIS THAT WE
FACE TODAY. AND THE NEED TO DO
AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO GET PEOPLE
OFF OUR STREETS AND INTO
HOUSING. THIS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL WILL INCREASE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A PHONE FUNDING FOR H.
H. A. P. THREE POINT OO AND I
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR TO MY
COLLEAGUES OUT THERE WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH RV. THAT ARE
ACTUALLY USED AS HOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS THIS FLEXIBLE
FUNDING CAN BE USED FOR RV
PARKING DOESN'T EXPLICITLY SAY
THAT BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT YOUR COUNTIES AND CITIES
CAN APPLY FOR THIS FUNDING FOR
RV PARKING. IN ADDITION IT HAS
MONEY SET ASIDE FOR ENCAMPMENT
RESOLUTION AGAIN WE KNOW SADLY
THERE ARE HOMELESS CAMPS THAT
ARE NOT ONLY UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT ACROSS OUR
STATE. AND IT IT DRESSES ACCESS
STATE LAND WHICH WE KNOW. WE
HAVE STATE LAND AND WE NEED TO
USE IT WE NEED TO USE THAT NOT
ONLY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT
FOR MENTAL HEALTH HOUSING AS WE
DID IN THE PAST I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ASK YOU TO SUPPORT AB
ONE FORTY. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FORTY JUST
WANTED TO COMPLIMENT OUR OUR
BUDGET CHAIR AND ALL OF THE
NEGOTIATORS ON OUR SIDE IN
PARTICULAR ON ONE PIECE OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS THE ENHANCED
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS THAT ARE
BUDGET CHAIR SPOKE ABOUT WHEN I
GO BACK TO MY DISTRICT I HEAR A
LOT OF FRUSTRATION ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THE LACK OF PROGRESS
THAT WE HAVE MADE. ON ON
HOMELESSNESS AND THE LACK OF
PROGRESS OF THE CITY IN THE
COUNTY HAVE MADE ON THAT I
THINK IT'S LONG PAST TIME THAT
WE ARE DOING MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY BRINGING MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO HOW WE ARE
SPENDING THIS MONEY THAT WE'RE
ALLOCATING TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN CONTINUANCE OF CARE
SO WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AND
WHICH AREN'T AND I KNOW THAT-THAT PUSH FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
SOMETHING THAT THIS HOUSE HAS
CHAMPION THAT IT'S BEEN THE
MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE. THAT
HAVE DEMANDED THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE IS A GOOD
START IN THIS TRAILER BILL
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
HERE THEIR BILLS WORKING
THROUGH THE PROGRESS THAT ARE
CAN BE CONTINUE THAT EFFORT FOR
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS WE OWE IT TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING ON
THE STREETS WE OWE IT TO
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE FRUSTRATED
WITH HOMELESSNESS WE OWE IT TO
THE PROVIDERS TO HAVE A GOOD
SENSE OF WHICH PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING WHICH PROGRAMS DESERVE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AND SO I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
BUDGET CHAIR. THANK YOU TO THE
BUDGET STAFF AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO WORKED ON THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE OF IT WE
WILL CONTINUE THAT WORK AND
WITH THAT WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON AB ONE FORTY. NAME IS
GABRIEL MISTER BLOOM. YOUR
ADDRESS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER FOR ALL THE REASONS
THAT IF I JUST BEEN STATED BY
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND- FROM OUR BUDGET
CHEN BUYER BUDGET CHAIR. OF
THIS BILL IS A MOMENTOUS
ACHIEVEMENT IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HOMELESSNESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE HAVE MULTI YEAR
FUNDING FOR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES AND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL MAKE THIS PROGRAM.
PERMANENT HOMELESSNESS IS A
STATEWIDE CRISIS AND WE NEED A
ROBUST STATEWIDE RESPONSE AS
HAS UNFORTUNATELY BEEN
FREQUENTLY OBSERVED LOS ANGELES
IS THE EPICENTER OF THIS CRISIS
AND- L. A. COUNTY WAS ONE OF
THE FEW JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT
A POINT TIME COUNT TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT SHOWED AN INCREASE
OF 13% FROM TWENTY NINETEEN. AS
WE LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
THIRD AND FOURTH ROUNDS OF THIS
PROGRAM AND HOPEFULLY A
PERMANENT PROGRAM. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDING
FORMULAS ARE RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE CRISIS EXISTS. MANY OF US
IN THE ALLEY REGION OF
EXPRESSED CONCERNS OVER THE
CAPS IN THIS BILL ON THE
ALLOCATIONS IT WOULD GO TO THE
LA AREA. IF HOMELESSNESS GROWS
IN LOS ANGELES THAN OUR STATE
PROGRAM SHOULD RESPOND TO THAT
NEED AND BE ABLE TO BE NIMBLE
SO THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN HAVE THE RESOURCES. THAT
THEY NEED TO GET PEOPLE HOUSING
AND SERVICES. SO I HOPE WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO FIND A
SOLUTION TO ENSURE THAT THIS
FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED
EQUITABLY. AND RESPONSIVE TO
THE CHANGING NEEDS ON THE
GROUND AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I AM
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS HISTORIC
LEGISLATION AND THE MANY
IMPROVEMENTS IN THIS- ITERATION
OF THE PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
BONUS POTS OF FUNDING FOR
PERFORMING JURISDICTIONS THAT
WILL BRING RESOURCES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THANK YOU ASHLEE
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OUR COLLEAGUES AS
YOU'VE HEARD AND AS WE ALL KNOW
IN THE MIDST OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY THIS
YEAR WE MAKE A HISTORIC
INVESTMENT IN HOMELESSNESS MORE
THAN WE'VE EVER SPENT TO
ADDRESS SUFFERING ON OUR
STREETS A TOTAL OF TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. INCLUDING TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AS WE KNOW IN
RECENT YEARS AS SIGNIFICANT
FUNDS HAVE BEEN SPENT AROUND
THE STATE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. POLICYMAKERS AND
THE PUBLIC HAVE SHARED A COMMON
FRUSTRATION OF WONDERING HOW
THIS MONEY IS ACTUALLY
IMPACTING THE CRISIS ON OUR
STREETS AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT
IN AB ONE FORTY THIS BILL
REQUIRED THAT ARE HOMELESSNESS
INVESTMENTS HAVE MORE COUNT
ABILITY THAN EVER BEFORE LET ME
JUST DELINEATES SOME OF THEM.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS ACTION PLANS
INCLUDE ASSESSMENTS OF EXISTING
RESOURCES AND DESCRIBE HOW
STATE FUNDING WILL FILL GAPS.
CITIES COUNTIES AND CONTINUES
OF CARE WILL NEED TO ESTABLISH
OUTCOME GOALS AND MEET THOSE
GOALS TO ACCESS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. THIS BILL CREATES REAL
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES IN
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE TO APPLY
FOR FUNDING TOGETHER AND GIVEN
THE MANY STATE AGENCIES
INVOLVED STATE AGENCIES WILL BE
REQUIRED TO IDENTIFY EXISTING
RESOURCES STATEWIDE THAT
ADDRESS THE CRISIS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TO
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
HOMELESSNESS BUT WE ALL KNOW
THERE IS MORE WORK TO DO. WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT WE RECEIVE
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
STATE AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY RESOURCES NEEDED TO
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS. WE NEED TO
REMAIN DILIGENT SO THAT THIS
HISTORIC INVESTMENT SUPPORTS
EVIDENCE BASED SOLUTIONS AND
PRODUCES RESULTS WE KNOW THAT
pREAL ACCOUNTABILITY WILL
REQUIRE DILIGENCE ON THE PART
OF BOTH THE STATE. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND WE ALL
APPRECIATE THAT SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT JUST
PROVIDING TEMPORARY SHELTER THE
BUILDING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK OUR
BUDGET LEADERSHIP THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD. AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS ISSUE.
WE ARE ALL COMMITTED TO A LONG
TERM INVESTMENT AND ONGOING
RESOURCES AND WE NEED TO DO
THIS. UNTIL WE END HOMELESSNESS
WE END THE MORAL CRISIS OF THE
STATE WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MR CHIU MISS REAVIS YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- I A ONE AT A LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SANTA MONICA THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY- SAN FRANCISCO
ON HOW HISTORIC THIS IS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- TO BE
COMMITTED TO AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE FOR HOMELESSNESS- THIS
IS. OF SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL BENEFIT FROM
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
BUDGET CHAIR ARE BUDGET SUB
CHAIR FROM LOS ANGELES- FOR
WORKING HARD TO ALSO INCLUDE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES- FOR
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I THINK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE STATE WE
CAN REALLY WORK TOWARDS ENDING
HOMELESSNESS THIS IS A PRIORITY
FOR MANY OF US IN OUR
DISTRICTS- AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK- EVERYONE INVOLVED
INCLUDING THE COALITIONS. THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKING TOWARDS THIS
AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
WILL PARTNER WITH US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS THANK YOU
MEMBERS. C. NOTICE DISK OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. IS THERE.
ALL THE VOTERS OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
HARTWELL CLOSE ROOM TIED OUT I
FIFTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN AND
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE THIS
IS AB ONE FOUR EIGHT AB ONE
FORTY EIGHT CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FORTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN I
BELIEVE IN THE PUBLIC RESOURCES
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
STICK AFFECT MILITARILY TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER K. THANK YOU TO
BE ONE FORTY EIGHT IS OUR
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL THIS
PROVIDES ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
WATER DISTRICTS. TO HELP THEM
WITH SOMEBODY- WATER USERS WHO
HAVE UNPAID BILLS THIS
PRIORITIZE A SMALL WATER
DISTRICTS IN PARTICULAR AND
ALSO PRIORITIZES DISTRICTS BY
THE LEVEL OF DEBT THAT THEY
HAVE. THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES
TEMPORARY FLEXIBILITY FOR STATE
AGENCIES SPENDING DROUGHT
RELIEF FUNDS TO REDUCE DELAYS
IN GETTING THE MONEY OUT OF THE
DOOR. TRANSFERS THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE WATER BOND FOR
WATER EFFICIENCY PROJECTS IN
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION IS TO WAIVE FEES
FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND
FOURTH GRADERS. SO THAT THEY
CAN VISIT OUR STATE PARKS THE
BILL VISIT ALSO FIXES THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE OIL
SPILL PREVENTION ADMINISTRATION
FUND. BY RAISING THE FEE CAP BY
TWO CENTS PER BARREL WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE. VOTE
ON AB ONE FORTY IT. THANK
RUSHED MR FONG. BUT YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. A MEMBERS CALIFORNIA
AS A POWERHOUSE WHEN IT COMES
ENERGY PRODUCTION IN KERN
COUNTY WHICH I'M PROUD
REPRESENT ENERGY PRODUCTION AS
A WAY OF LIFE FOR MY COMMUNITY
THAT IS TAKEN FOR GRANTED
SACRAMENTO KERN COUNTY ALONE
PRODUCES ABOUT 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL MORE THAN 90% OF
OUR STATE'S NATURAL GAS ALL
WHILE COMPLYING WITH THE MOST
STRICT LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. WERE ALSO A LEADER
IN RENEWABLE ENERGY AS A
LEADING COUNTY IN WIND ENERGY
PRODUCTION AS WELL AS SOLAR
ENERGY PRODUCTION WE ARE SEEING
HEADLINE AFTER HEADLINE
DISCUSSING THE PRECARIOUS
SITUATION OUR STATE IS IN WHEN
IT COMES TO RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE ENERGY. BUT THIS
BILL PROVIDES MORE FEES AND
REGULATIONS THE ONLY THREATEN
TO DRIVE UP THE COST OF ENERGY
FOR OUR FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES
THESE ACTIONS ARE TAKEN AT A
TIME WHEN OUR STATE HAS
RESOURCES TO INVEST TO AVOID
THESE FEE INCREASES EVEN WORSE
AT AT AT AT A TIME WHEN THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD'S ABILITY TO COLLECT
DATA. TO ASSESS THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THEIR
OPERATIONS AND PROGRAMS
CONFIRMED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
THIS BILL CONTAINS PROVISIONS
THAT WAIVE THIS IMPORTANT
REVIEWS OF THEIR PROGRAMS AT A
TIME WHEN WE NEED MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN OUR GOVERNMENT THIS BILL
GOES IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE I.
STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU WISH FONG SEEN NO
DISCUSSION. OUR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CORPORAL JARABO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SERVER. MARKWELL
CLOSER ROLE. TYLER I FIFTY
THREE NO SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE THIRTY THREE IS
AT THE DESK I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SIXTY THREE AND SEVENTY
SEVEN TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM TO TAKE UP EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY THREE TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE. AMENDMENTS. WE SHOP
MISTER FLORA. WE WILL HOLD
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AS FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING. MISTER CHOW MOVES
AND MR TANG SECONDS ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BATCH PLEASE. SURE WELL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BATCH
THESE PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE FIFTY
THREE IS AT THE DESK I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE AND
SEVENTY SEVEN TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY THREE TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. FINALLY AB
THREE THIRTY ONE IS AT THE DESK
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN. TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER JO JONES
SAWYER TO TAKE UP AB THREE
THIRTY THREE TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
THANK WHICH SHALL MISTER FLORA
WITHHOLDING ASK IT'S ENOUGH FOR
ROLL CALL THE- MISS.
RESEARCH
MISTER CHARITY OF A
CLARIFICATION ON THE BILL
NUMBER YES LET ME REPEAT AB
THREE THIRTY ONE IS AT THE DESK
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WE SIXTY THREE
AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO ALLOW SOME
ACCIONES SORRY TO TAKE UP AB
THREE THIRTY ONE TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. MISTER FLOOR
IS STILL WITHHOLDING. MISTER
SHALL MOUSSA MR TANG SECONDS
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MR CHOW IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR
AND NOVO. THIS IS PROCEDURAL
MISTER CHOW'S ASKING FOR NINE
MISTER FLORA I KNOW.
MISTER
CHOW IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MR FLOOR NO CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE. I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS
NINETEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
OKAY. MEMBERS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS
IS AB ONE THIRTY THREE WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THIRTY THREE SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY THREE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NATURALLY THE HEALTH MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BEVERLY TO THE
BUDGET MISTER TAYLOR MAY OPEN.
MEMBERS I STAND RISE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ALL OF US ARE AB ONE
THIRTY THREE WHICH IS ARE. ON
THE BEST HEALTH TRAILER BILL.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
EXPANSIONS IN PUBLIC HEALTH IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY. THE ME
JUST SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
BUDGET SUB CHAIRS WILL OF ALL
THE MEMBERS OF BUDGET SUB ONE.
WHO CONSTANTLY HERE HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING AND TALKING ABOUT THE
NEED FOR GREATER. PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PARTICULAR
IT'S ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS OVERALL FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR A HUGE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INVESTMENT IN OUR CAL
AIM INITIATIVE. R. MY COLLEAGUE
IN OUR CHAIR FROM FRESNO TALKED
ABOUT THE NEED TO EXPAND
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY AND
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY IS GONNA
BE EXPANDED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOW FIFTY AND OVER. REGARDLESS
OF YOUR DOCUMENTATION STATUS.
OF FOR OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
ROSA THE BILL ALSO IMPLEMENTS
OUR OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL AS- OUR HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. IN A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS ARE IN HERE AS WELL IN
TERMS OF HOLDS A WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING. THE HEALTH CAREERS
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM AND
EXPANSION OF TELEHEALTH OF
FLEXIBILITIES FOR ANOTHER YEAR
IT INCREASES THE MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
CLINICAL LABORATORY SERVICES.
LASTLY THERE IS A FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
IN OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL MENTAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AFTER THIS YEAR I
COULDN'T THINK OF A MORE
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT. IN OUR
CHILDREN ARE USED MENTAL HEALTH
SO WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL ON THE B. ONE THIRTY
THREE. THANK WHICH TECHNICIAN
FONG I THINK IT WAS A SPEAKER
SUSTAINABILITY IS A COMMON
CONCERN THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE
BUDGET DEBATE THE LONG TERM
FISCAL VIABILITY OF THE
MEDICARE SYSTEM IS SOMETHING WE
MUST ALL BE WARY OF THIS BILL
DOES PROVIDE NEEDED SUPPORT OF
THE CAL IMAGE OF TO BETTER
DELIVER CARE TO OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM WAS PUT UNDER IMMENSE
PRESSURE TO RESPOND TO COVER
NINETEEN NO DOUBT THE PANDEMIC
REVEALED A NUMBER OF STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES IN DELIVERING AND
PROVIDING NEEDED HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. BUT THIS BILL
ULTIMATELY ADDS UNAFFORDABLE
ONGOING COST PRESSURES TO A
STATE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT IS
NOT ON A SUSTAINABLE PATH
INSTEAD OF PILING MORE COSTS ON
TOP OF A STRUGGLING SYSTEM WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON IMPROVING
CURRENT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OUR
CURRENT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIANS I
REGRETFULLY URGE AND OF A- MS
AGUIAR-CURRY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THIRTY THREE BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
MEDICARE PATIENTS TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITIES FOR ONE MORE YEAR
AND I WANT TO THANK THE BUDGET
AND SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS AND THE
HEALTH POLICY CHAIR FOR HELPING
DELIVER WHAT WE COULD THIS YEAR.
FOLLOWING THESE FLEXIBILITIES
REMAIN PATIENTS CAN CONTINUE TO
SEE THEIR PROVIDERS CREATING A
BRIDGE TOOK EXPAND ACCESS IN
MORE NORMAL TIMES. HOWEVER THIS
IS NOT A PERMANENT SOLUTION AND
I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT WE ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO DO MORE DURING
THE SESSION. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THROUGH AB THIRTY TWO I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH A BROAD
COALITION OF SAFETY NET CLINICS
PATIENT ADVOCATES HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS HOSPITALS AND
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEES. TO ENSURE
THAT TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITIES
BECOME PERMANENT AFTER THE
PANDEMIC. THROUGH THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS CALLED OUT
IN AB ONE THIRTY THREE AND I
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AB THIRTY
TWO WE NEED TO LOCK IN ACCESS
TO ALL TELEHEALTH MODALITIES.
THAT WERE CRITICAL TO PEOPLE
GETTING HEALTH CARE SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE NEED TO
COLLECT DATA TO ENSURE QUALITY
AND THE BEST HEALTH OUTCOMES.
WE NEED TO EXPAND THE SERVICES
TO COMMERCIAL PROVIDERS AND WE
NEED TO BE APPROPRIATELY
REIMBURSED ALL PROVIDERS SO
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO OFFER
REAL TELEHEALTH ACCESS. ALL
SEVENTY EIGHT MEMBERS WHO WERE
PRESENT THAT DAY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR VOTE ON AB
THIRTY TWO SUPPORTED THESE KEY
COMPONENTS OF TELEHEALTH
ACCESS. WITH YOUR HELP I WILL
WORK I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS FIGHT DURING
THE UPCOMING YEAR IN ENSURING
PERMANENT ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. VIA TELEHEALTH FOR
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU. MS FRIEDMAN HERE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HELD ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IS
ONE OF THE TOP CONCERNS FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND WITH THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
NATION IN TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
OUR RESIDENTS HAVE ACCESS. TO
QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE. BUT ON TODAY WHICH IS
THE- A CELEBRATION FOR IN
FRANCE OF BEST DEAL DAY LET'S
COMMIT OURSELVES TO PUSHING FOR
A REVOLUTION IN HEALTH CARE TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN CALIFORNIA. YES
COVERAGE THAT IS AFFORDABLE AND
QUALITY THANK YOU. THANKS
FRIEDMAN DR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- THIS IS A
BIG BILL AND THERE IS A LOT TO
LOVE ABOUT THIS BILL MAKES A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT CHANGES
INCLUDING A NUMBER OF
SIGNIFICANT SICK SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. INCLUDING ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATING THE ASSET TEST ONE
OF THE THINGS I WANT TO CALL
OUT THIS BILL WHICH WAS
MENTIONED BY OUR OF OUR BUDGET
CHAIR FROM SAN FRANCISCO IS
THAT IS THAT IT IMPLEMENTS
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING MEDIC
CAL PROPOSAL ALSO KNOWN AS
CAROLYN. KELLY WILL MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO IMPROVE
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM THESE
INCLUDE IMPROVING HOW SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED TO SENIORS PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER
ENSURING THE PEOPLE LEAVING
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES RECEIVE
A WARM HAND OFF AND ENROLLED IN
COVERAGE. IT ALSO EXPANDS THE
SERVICES THAT MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS CAN PROVIDE TO
ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH AND ADDRESS HIGH NEEDS
POPULATION I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE- THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICE
LEADERSHIP. TEAM FOR THEIR
YEARS OF WORK IN PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER IN PARTICULAR I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE WORK OF
DIRECTOR WILL LIFE FORM AND J.
C. COOPER THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WHO IS THE LEAD ARCHITECT OF
THIS PROPOSAL. BUT THERE'S A
PIECE MISSING IN THIS PROPOSAL
IN THIS IN THIS BILL AND THAT'S
AROUND AFFORDABILITY. THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT PROPOSAL THAT I
HOPE WILL COME UP- IN AUGUST SO
WE CAN TALK ABOUT. EIGHT OUT OF
TEN CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE THAT.
HELP THE COST OF HEALTHCARE IS
EITHER EXTREMELY IMPORTANT OR
VERY IMPORTANT AND IF CALLED
UPON THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE MOVE SOMETHING
FORWARD. THERE IS A PROPOSAL
AROUND HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYBODY IS IN
THE MORE PEOPLE WHO GET LEFT
LET OUT OF THIS POLICY. WILL
GREATLY DIMINISH THE ABILITY
FOR THAT TO BE EFFECTIVEWE OWE
IT TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND NOT JUST THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE BENEFITING FROM STATE
PROGRAMS BUT EVERYONE ELSE. TO
FIND A WAY TO KEEP THE COST OF
HEALTH CARE MORE AFFORDABLE.
HEALTH CARE CONTINUES TO RISE
AT TWICE THE RATE OF INFLATION.
AND WITH INFLATION INCREASING
NOW. START HERE MORE AND MORE
ABOUT INFLATION INCREASING
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MORE AND
MORE RISES IN THE COST OF
HEALTH CARE. CONSUMERS CAN'T
AFFORD IT. WE NEED TO DO BETTER
AND I HOPE THAT IN AUGUST WILL
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON THAT PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE. GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I. FOR DR
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE THIRTY THREE THIS
YEAR'S HEALTH TRAILER BILL- AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS
BILL TAKES EXTRAORDINARY STEPS
TO ADDRESS HEALTH DISPARITIES
WHICH ARE CAUSED BY SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH BY
CHANGING THE VERY SYSTEM THAT A
THIRD OF ALL CALIFORNIANS RELY
ON FOR HEALTH CARE. BY
STREAMLINING TRANSFORMING AND
FOUNDATION WE CHANGING THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM IN THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCING AND
INNOVATING MEDICAL. CALLING
WILL INVEST IN POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT WILL WHICH
WILL ALLOW US TO PRIORITIZE
WELLNESS AND PREVENTIVE
SERVICES IT WILL ALSO ALLOW US
TO IDENTIFY AND MITIGATE MANY
OF THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. IT ALSO WILL SUPPORT IN
LIEU OF SERVICES WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO HAVE SERVICES LIKE
HOUSING TRANSITION NAVIGATION
SERVICES OR ASTHMA REMEDIATION
OR HOUSING DEPOSITS OR
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS THAT
WILL BETTER ALLOW US TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR COMMUNITIES. IT
ALSO WILL INVEST INTO AN
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT WHICH
IS AN ABILITY FOR US TO HAVE A
WHOLE PERSON CARE. WHICH MANY
OF YOU IN YOUR COUNTIES HAVE
BUT THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
EQUITABLY APPLY IT TO THE
REMAINDER OF THE STATE. FURTHER
IT CHANGES THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM FOR ADULTS BUT I
WANT TO CALL OUT IN AGREES
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
INVEST IN THE HEALTH CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. WHICH IS
WILL ADDRESS THE URGENT AND
GROWING NEED IN OUR STATES TO
EXPAND THE POOL OF TALENTED
DIVERSE. HEALTH WORKERS AND TO
CONNECT THEM MORE EFFECTIVELY
IN ALL OF OUR STATE. I AM
THRILLED THAT THIS BUDGET
SUPPORTS HEALTH FOR ALL AND
EXPANDING FULL SCOPE MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO THOSE WHO ARE OVER
THE AGE OF FIFTY. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT OUR STATE NOW
PROTECT ALL LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY WERE BORN. THE
HEALTH OF EACH OF US IS
DEPENDENT ON THE HEALTH OF ALL
OF US AND THIS IS A BUDGET THAT
BUILDS BACK BOLDLY BY INVESTING
IN ALL CALIFORNIANS. I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP STAKEHOLDERS THE
PUBLIC MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR SEEN NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
CARPAL OF THE ROLE. MEMBERS
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY FIVE KNOWS FIVE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN AND WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIFTY THREE ONE FIVE THREE.
SEPARATE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIFTY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACCURATE IN THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES AND
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR
SIGNIFICANT MEDIALLY PRIVILEGE
THE BUDGET. MISTER TECH. THANK
YOU AB ONE FIFTY THREE IS OUR
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES TRAILER
BILL WHILE THIS IS NOT. THE
MOST HIGH PROFILE BILLS
PROBABLY ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT BILLS. BECAUSE IT.
REFERS TO AND HELPS TO REFORM
OUR CHILD WELFARE IN OUR FOSTER
CHILD SYSTEM. THESE ARE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN MANY
OF WHOM WHO DON'T HAVE PARENTS
THAT OFTEN ARE OVERLOOKED FOR
TOO LONG WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH
FOR THEM. THIS BILL WORKS TO
STABILIZE THE FAMILY SITUATIONS
THAT WORKS TO REALLY FOCUS ON
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THOSE
CHILDREN. ESTABLISHES A
PROHIBITION ON OUT OF STATE
PLACEMENTS EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH THE
RETURN. OF ALL CHILDREN FROM
OUT OF STATE BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. EXTENDS
THE INFANT. SUPPLEMENT FOR
PREGNANT FOSTER YOUTH IT ALSO
CREATES THE GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOT FOR PRIORITY WITH THE
PRIORITY FOR FOSTER YOUTH
IMPACT A PERSON'S. INCREASE A
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT. TO AID IN
THE HOUSE INSTABILITY FOR OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH IN CERTAIN HIGH
COST COUNTY AGAIN THESE ARE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN
THIS BILL TAKES A HUGE STEP. TO
STABILIZING THEIR LIVES AND TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR FAMILIES ARE
TAKEN CARE OF WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR A VOTE ON
AB ONE FIFTY THREE. THANK WHICH
TO FONG. BUT YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS CHILD WELFARE IS
SOMETHING WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
THIS BILL WILL BRING FOSTER
CHILDREN BACK INTO OUR STATE TO
HELP CONNECT THEM WITH NEEDED
SERVICES AND FIND THEM HOMES AS
WE CONTINUE TO UNDO FUNDING
SUSPENSIONS MADE LAST YEAR WE
CAN BEGIN TO RETURN TO NORMAL
AND STABILIZE THE PORT SYSTEMS
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED IT
MOST. THIS MEASURE HOWEVER
INCLUDES A UNIVERSAL INCOME
PILOT PROGRAM A CONCEPT THAT
COULD UNDERMINE INCENTIVES TO
WORK AND INCREASED DEPENDENCE
ON GOVERNMENT WE SHOULD BE
PUSHING POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE
THE VALUE OF WORK GUARANTEED
INCOME DOESN'T PROVIDE THE JOB
TRAINING AND SKILLS NEEDED FOR
UPWARD MOBILITY WITHOUT THAT
ASSURANCE. I CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU MR
MR COOLEY YOUR RECOGNIZE.
CALLING SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO
ON THIS FOR WE TRY TO CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF CHILDREN'S
LIVES. AND THE TRUTH IS THAT
OUR STATE DIFFERENT KIDS START
THAT RACE WITH DIFFERENT ASSETS
TO STAND UP FOR OUR FOSTER CARE
TO BLEND SUPPORT FOR THEM IN
THEIR OPPORTUNITIES AND LONG
TERM PROSPECTS THIS IS.
DRAMATICALLY IMPORTANT IT'S A
VITAL ROLE FOR STATE GOVERNMENT
TO LOOK TO THESE. YOUTHS AND
SUPPORT THEM HIGHER GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. ISRAELI
TERRORISTS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER- QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
DOES THIS UNIVERSAL INCOME
PROGRAM HAVE A SUNSET DATE AND
FOR HOW LONG WOULD THEY BE
ELIGIBLE. I'M NOT SURE IF THE
PILOTS I ASSUME IT'S FOR A SET
AMOUNT OF TIME AND HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON ELIGIBILITY.
GREAT THANK YOU. NOW SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. CLICK
LIBERAL. IS THERE. TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS SERVICE ACT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE. TALLY
THE VOTE. I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. HEY MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS IT'S ONE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE WHAT IT INCREDIBLE
AND ONCE IN A LIFETIME BUDGET-
WE ARE PASSING IN CONTINUING TO
PASS BECAUSE WE KNOW THE WORK
CONTINUES I WANT TO THANK.
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HELPED TO
MAKE THIS THIS POSSIBLE THUS
FAR- OBVIOUSLY ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF OUR BODY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK IN
YOUR INPUT IN THE BUDGET
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK. HI
MISTER CHANG OUR BUDGET SHARE
THIS IS A PHENOMENAL BUDGET AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK ON
YOUR PART. HAVE OUR WEEKLY
MEETINGS THAT START IN JANUARY.
WHEN IT STARTED IN JANUARY
MEETING TARTED IN JANUARY WE
DIDN'T. QUITE KNOW WHERE WE'D
BE AT THIS POINT- BUT THE FACT
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO ROLL WITH
THE PUNCHES AND THEN. PRODUCE
SUCH INCREDIBLE BUDGET. SAYS A
LOT ABOUT YOU AND I KNOW YOU
ALSO WANT ME TO. THANK AND
MENTION YOUR STAFF TO DO
PHENOMENAL WORK SO THANK YOU
MISTER TAYLOR STAFF. I WANT TO
THANK OUR VICE CHAIR MISTER
PHONE YOUR FIRST TIME OUT NOT
BAD IT'S NOT IT'S NOT ALWAYS AS
GOOD AS. BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHENOMENAL WORK. AND I WANT TO
THINK OF THE BUDGET SUB SHARES
DR ARAMBULA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK. MR MCCARTY THERE YOU
ARE MISTER MCCARTY THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK. MISTER
BLOOM THANK YOU SO MUCH. MS
CARILLO PHENOMENAL WORK GREAT
WORK. AND MS GARCIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK
GARCIA. POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I REALLY WANT TO
THANK JASON SISTEMA BUDGET
DIRECTOR FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK
FACE TO FACE. MISTER K. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LET LET LET ME JUST
ALSO ADDED THE THANK YOUS SO ON
TOP OF WITH THE SPEAKER
RECOGNIZED. WANT TO THANK
CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH AS WELL AS
OUR ENTIRE. BUDGET TEAM MISTER
SHOULD STOCK IN THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS BUDGET TEAM. COUNTLESS
COUNTLESS HOURS AND MAJORITY
LEADER ASKED ME HOW MANY HOURS
THAT WE SPEND THIS BUDGET I
REALLY CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO
QUALIFY- BUT ALSO LET ME THINK
ARE ILLEGAL WHO AGAIN IS OUR
ANALYST FOR. ALL THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE REALLY RELY ON
THEIR ANALYSIS SUPPORT TO GET
THROUGH THIS BUDGET LET ME ALSO
THANK. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR THEIR- INCREDIBLE WORK. I
KNOW THAT AS ALL EIGHTY OF US
COME UP. AND DOWN EVERY SINGLE
WEEK WE ALL WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THE LIVES. OF PEOPLE IN
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
OUR DISTRICT IS BETTER OFF. AND
FOR THIS BUDGET WE'VE DONE A
HUGE INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR JOB IS TO MAKE
SURE THROUGH OUR OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
SPEND IT THE RIGHT WAY WILL BE
DOING THAT. GOING INTO THE
FOLLOWING GOING INTO NEXT YEAR
SO JUST WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
PARTICIPATION. IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS. AND MR FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HER. I JUST QUICKLY
WANTED TO THINK- AS WELL THE-
ARE BUDGET CHAIR- CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW I DON'T AGREE ON
EVERYTHING BUT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE RELATIONSHIP AND
THE WORKING. ENVIRONMENT THAT
THAT WE'VE HAD AND FORGED I IN
TERMS OF WORKING TOGETHER AND I
ALSO DO WANT TO THINK THAT THE
STAFF- ON THE ROOF OF THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE JOCHEN STOCK IN
OUR STAFF AND OUR OUR OUR
CONSULTANTS. HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY- TRYING TO SCRAMBLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT- THERE ARE
SIDE AS PREPARED- AND SO I
REALLY WANTED TO PROVIDE THEM
THAT RECOGNITION AS WELL. K.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE
DOES ANY MEMBER OBJECT TO
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION TO MS
RADIUS TO TAKE AMENDMENTS. IS
FILE ITEM FORTY SEEING AND
HEARING NINE. CLERK WILL READ
FILE ITEM FORTY AB SIX FIFTY
FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY FOUR WITH LIMITS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS MS RACE
ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
AMENDMENTS TO- TO EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR CLEAN UP AB WHICH
CLEANS UP EIGHTY SIX LIKE FIVE
FROM LAST YEAR. OUR THE
AMENDMENTS AIM TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY RELATING TO THE
DATABASE CREATED IN EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU MISS
REYES THAT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WERE IN
WITH A FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. SB
SEVEN OH NINE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL SEVEN
OH NINE WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY. THIS DALY
ON THE AMENDMENTS. MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDING SB
SEVEN OH NINE RELATED TO TIMBER
HARVEST PERMIT EXTENSIONS. THE
AMENDMENT WOULD SIMPLY ADD AN
URGENCY CLAUSE ALLOWING CAL
FIRE TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THE
BILL UPON THE GOVERNOR'S
SIGNATURE. ENSURING THAT
IMPORTANT FOREST MANAGEMENT
WORK ON APPROVED T. H. P.'S CAN
CONTINUE UNINTERRUPTED
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE MINUTES HE
ADOPTED IN THE BILL GO BACKED
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON THE
FILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
ALLEY WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE PHONE IS A MEMBERS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVEN'T.
BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE. I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE MS
DAVIS FOR A VOTE CHANGE THIS IS
JUST MS DAVIS ON OF A CHANGE.
AND DAVIS YOUR RECORDS THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES
MAKES A VOTE CHANGE ON SB ONE
THREE THREE FROM EIGHT TO
OPPOSE. BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY THREE I TO KNOW. MEMBERS
WE ARE TAKING UP AMENDMENTS AT
THIS TIME THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SB THREE FIFTY THREE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORPORAL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY THREE
WITH A MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN. MR WENT
ON THE AMENDMENTS SB THREE A
FIVE THREE IS UP FOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS. AND ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAME THE EYES HAVE
IT. THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT TO FRIENDS AND
BACKGROUND FILES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE. FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE. H. R. SIXTY
CORPORATE. HOUSE RESOLUTION
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
RELATIVE TO THE FEDERAL ENDING
INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOL
INITIATIVE. MR BONTA S. YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS TO PRESENT
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY AUTHORED
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW IN RECENT
MONTHS THE UNMARKED GRAVES IN
MORE THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
NATIVE CHILDREN WERE UNCOVERED
AT INDIAN RESIDENTIAL SCHOOLS
ACROSS CANADA. THE HISTORY WE
LEARNED IN SCHOOLS ARE ALL TOO
OFTEN GLOSSED OVER THE
ATROCITIES PERPETRATED AGAINST
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES IN
THE FIRST NATIONS WITH THE
CIVILIAN FIND ACT OF EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN CONGRESS SOUGHT TO
ASSIMILATE INTO RACE NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURE. BY SEPARATING
NATIVE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND SENDING THEM TO
BOARDING SCHOOLS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF FORCED ASSIMILATION
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE OFTEN NOT
INFORMED WHEN THE NATIVE
CHILDREN AT THESE SCHOOLS FELL
ILL AND EVEN DIED AND EVEN WHEN
ENQUIRIES ABOUT THEIR WELL
BEING WERE MADE. THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT INCLUDE SHERMAN
INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL WHICH OPENED
IN EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO AS A
PARRIS INDIAN SCHOOL IT
RELOCATED TO THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE IN NINETEEN OH THREE
THE SHERMAN INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL
WAS ONE OF HUNDREDS OF INDIAN
BOARDING SCHOOLS IN THE UNITED
STATES ESTABLISHED. UNDER THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN CIVILIANS
THEY CIVILIZATION FIND ACT DUE
TO THE DISCOVERIES OF UNMARKED
GRAVES IN CANADA U. S.
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR DEB
HAALAND THE FIRST NATIVE
AMERICAN CABINET SECRETARY HAS
CALLED FOR AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE LOST OF HUMAN LIFE. AT
INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOLS ACROSS
AMERICA THE INTERIOR DEPARTMENT.
WAS IDENTIFIED INDIAN BOARDING
SCHOOL. AUSTIN ON THE TO FIND.
STORY BURIAL SITES HUNDRED
YEARS GROUNDS I A SITE OF IN
BOARDING SCHOOLS CALIFORNIA
MUST VOICE ITS UNWAVERING
SUPPORT FOR THIS FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION WE MUST DETERMINE
HOW MANY NATIVE CHILDREN LOST
THEIR LIVES DUE TO CRUEL
POLICY. OF FORCED ASSIMILATION
EMBODIED BY THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN CIVILIZATION FIND ACT.
PASSAGE OF THIS RESOLUTION WILL
SHOW THAT THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS FULLY SUPPORTS
THE INTERIOR DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION IT IS BEYOND TIME
THAT WE FIND THE TRUTH AND
BRING TO LIFE TO THE FULL
SCOPE. OF THE HORRORS
EXPERIENCED BY OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND THE FIRST
NATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ASK THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR A CO AUTHORS. THANK
YOU MR MATTIS MR BONTA SESSION
OF THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS. SORRY MR RAHMAN
HERE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE FOR
BRINGING UP THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT DEALS WITH ALL-
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE AND
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKER
THIS BODY FOR MOVING FORWARD ON
THE FIRST- EVER CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IN THIS IS THE FIRST
RESOLUTION THAT WE'RE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF THAT
CAUCUS. THAT'S THEIR- THIS BILL
THIS- HOUSE RESOLUTION SEEKS TO
SUPPORT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THEIR INVESTIGATION INTO
THE BOARDING SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED HERE THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT ALSO BRINGS
ATTENTION TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
CANADA RIGHT NOW WITH OVER A
THOUSAND GRAVES BEING
UNCOVERED. WE START TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THAT
MANY THERE GREW UP ON
INDIAN RESERVATIONS HAVE COME
TO LEARN THE STORIES. OF PEOPLE
THAT WENT TO THE BOARDING
SCHOOLS AND NEVER RETURNED HOME
AND STILL ARE ASKING QUESTIONS
NOW OF HOW DID THEY SUCCUMB TO
THAT DEBT. THAT DEBT THAT SOME
OF SAID MIGHT BE AN ACCIDENT
SOME OF SAID IT COULD BE FROM
DIFFERENT NATURAL CAUSES BUT-
THERE'S ALSO SOME THAT SAY.
THAT IT WAS BROUGHT ON THROUGH
ASSAULT AND PHYSICAL ATTACKS
THAT WERE THERE THOSE THINGS
WERE NEVER INVESTIGATED DURING
THIS TIME OF ERA. AN ERA THE
VIEW THAT THE INDIAN PEOPLE AND
THESE BOARDING SCHOOLS WERE RAN
WITH A SLOGAN A SLOGAN THAT
SAID KILL THE INDIAN TO SAVE
THE MAN. THAT ASSIMILATION
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD UP
UNTIL THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
AND REPRESENTATION TRULY DOES
MATTER AS WE SEE THE FIRST
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
CALLING FOR AN INVESTIGATION
THAT MANY OF US IS CALLED FOR
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS. SHE'S
FINALLY DOING IT. AND I BELIEVE
BY DOING THIS HOUSE RESOLUTION
SHOWS OUR SUPPORT HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THIS
ASSEMBLY AS WE CONTINUE AS THE
ASSEMBLY TO MOVE FORWARD. ON
ISSUES ISSUES THAT A DETRIMENT
TO THE INDIAN PEOPLE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ABROAD SUCH AS THE MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN THAT
THIS BODY. TOOK FORWARD AND IS
NOW MOVING FOR WITH ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO BRING INVESTIGATIONS
TO THOSE. REPRESENTATION TRULY
DOES MATTER. THAT'S WHY WITH
THE TAKIS THE NATIVE A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
LEGISLATIVE POPULOUS WE STAND
WHOLLY. IN SOLIDARITY WITH ALL
OF OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THESE
THINGS DO MOVE FORWARD THAT WE
STAND UNITED TO BRING FORWARD A
ERA IN HISTORY. A DARK HISTORY
THAT HAS PLAGUED THE KID THE
INDIAN PEOPLE IS NOW COMING TO
LIGHT. THE ISSUE ISN'T ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY THE ISSUE IS
LET'S LEARN FROM THE PAST AND
TRULY UNDERSTAND THAT DARK PART
OF HISTORY SO THAT WE COULD
TEACH IT TO OUR SCHOOL KIDS. SO
THAT OUR PEOPLE CAN FINALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT TRULY HAPPENED
TO THEIR LOVED ONES. THIS HOUSE
RESOLUTION WILL SUPPORT THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS MOVING FORWARD
TO UNCOVER WHAT TRULY HAPPENED
IN THE BOARDING SCHOOLS SO WE
CAN BRING RESULT IN HEALING
BACK TO OUR PEOPLE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ENGLISH ROMANCE SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. MISTER VONTAZE IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. NEVER CEASES FOR
CALL AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION. WE HAVE. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
LOCAL CLOSER
ROLE THERE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THIS IS.
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE AB
THREE THIRTY ONE BY MISTER
JONES SAWYER CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACCORDING TO PFAFF AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY OF STICK
FOR COMMUNITY MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB THREE THREE ONE IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
SENTIMENT SIMPLY RE ENACT US
PENAL CODE SECTION FOUR NINE
ZERO POINT FOUR WHICH HAD
SUNSET IT ON JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AB THREE THREE ONE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHNSON SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS FOR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
THE FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE THIS
IS MR MAIN TRANSMITTERS IT IS
REYES WILL PRESENT THIS IS.
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE AB EIGHT
FIFTY SIX CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
ACCOLADE OF PEOPLE HELPING TO
CLEAR THESE HERE DETERMINERS
HERE UP THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY. THIS RACE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB EIGHT
FIFTY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE CVE THE POSTMAN. AN
INFORMATION SHEET ON THE
WEBSITE FOR PEOPLE STATING. THE
CURRENT. COVERED NINETEEN
HEALTH RISKS. AND THE GRADUAL
RETURN TO PHYSICAL EXERCISE
GUIDELINES AMENDMENTS TAKEN.
THE SENATE AD AND URGENCY
CLAUSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MISS
REYES SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. MARKET CURTIN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE ARE AT SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE RESULT WILL
FIRST TAKE UP THE RESOLUTIONS
THAT ARE ON CONSENT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO THE
CURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AND
OTHERS RELATIVES OF VALLEY
FEVER AWARENESS MONTH HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIVING RELATIVES
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CLASS OF FOUR MILLION. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
SIX BY CIVIL MELENDEZ AND
OTHERS WELL IT'S A FAIR AMOUNT
I AM YOU KNOW ACID THE PHARMACY
TO FINISH DEFICIENCY AWARENESS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY ONE BY CENTER BRADFORD
OTHERS RELATIVE TO JUNETEENTH
SENATOR WAS LUCIEN FORTY FIVE
BY SEVEN DOT RELATIVE TO ELDER
INDEPENDENT BUTTE ABUSE
AWARENESS MONTH INCIDENT WAS
LUCIEN FORTY SEVEN BY CENTER
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS. RELATIVE
TO SECURE VISAS DAY. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE THIS IS TO
ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A
CO AUTHOR. THIS IS. THE
RESOLUTIONS. ON CONSENT. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS FOR THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED. MOVING
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF
IS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING ON THE CORPORATE
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AND OTHERS
RELATIVES OF VALLEY FEVER WERE
IN THIS MONTH. CLARK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WELL. CLOSER
ROLE THERE THE VOTED SIXTY NINE
ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS ADOPTED
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSTITUTION FIFTY THREE I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE BILL
FOUR NINETY EIGHT I SIXTY NINE
OH ZERO SENATE BILL TWO
NINETEEN WITH URGENCY I SIXTY
NINE OH ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY NINE IS HERE ON THE BILL
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY EIGHT I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO CYNICAL
THREE THIRTY THREE I SIXTY NINE
OH ZERO SUITABLE FOR ELEVEN I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE BILL
SIX THIRTY FOUR. I SIX NINE NO
ZERO SEVEN BILLION SEVENTEEN I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE BILL
EAT TWENTY ONE WITH URGENCY I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO THE URGENCY
I SIXTY NINE THOSE ARE ON THE
BILL SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX I SIXTY
NINE OH ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY ONE I SIXTY
RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE I SIXTY
NINE OH ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO IN SENATE BILL.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX. I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO. MEMBERS I AM WHOLE THE
DESK OPEN TO RECEIVE COMMITTEE
REPORTS SUBMITTED PURSUANT TO A
JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE.
ADDITIONALLY WITHOUT OBJECTION
I'M HOLDING THE DESK OPEN
DURING THE SUMMER RECESS. TO
RECEIVE BILLS RETURNED TO THE
DESK BY THE GOVERNOR. FOR
FURTHER ACTION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL THIS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS. TO THE
PLANE. MEMBERS WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE GERMANS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
GREEN CARPET AT THIS TIME. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS OF RAM PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE DAZ
BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF PASTOR REGINALD WALTON POPE
OF WHAT'S WHO WENT HOME TO BE
WITH THE LORD ON WEDNESDAY JUNE
JUNE THE SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE AT ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN PM. PASTOR POPE WAS BORN
ON AUGUST THE SEVENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE TO JOSEPH OLIVER
OLIVER POPE AND WILLIE CRAWFORD
POLK IN LOUISIANA. IN NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT HE MADE A BOLD MOVE
TO LOS ANGELES WHERE HE BECAME
WHERE HE WAS WELCOMED WITH OPEN
ARMS BY THE COMMUNITY. FOR
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY YOU MAY
REMEMBER. DR POLK- WE HONOR HIM
ON THIS FLOOR IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN BY THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS PRESENTING HIM
WITH THE RESOLUTION DURING
BLACK HISTORY. MONTH AND HE WAS
ABSOLUTELY THRILLED TO BE ON
THIS GREEN CARPET RECEIVING AN
AWARD- HERE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. HE DID SHINE A LIGHT.
ON OF THE COMMUNITY AS HE WAS A
PASTOR FOR MANY MANY YEARS OF
FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS AS A
PASTOR OF BETHEL MISSIONARY
BAPTIST CHURCH OF SOUTH LOS
ANGELES. EVEN AFTER HE RETIRED-
TO IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
PASSED THE POPE SAID IF GOD
CALLED ME TO PREACH YOU CAN'T
RETIRE FROM PREACHING PASTORING
YES BUT NOT PREACHING SO HE
KEPT ON PREACHING AFTER HE
RETIRED PASTOR POPE CONTINUED I
MEAN IS CALLING TO CREATE THE
REGINALD POPE A OUT REACH
MINISTRY. WHICH WORSHIP SERVICE
ON THE- BROADCAST LIVE VIA
SOCIAL MEDIA EVERY SUNDAY- AT
NINE AM HE LED A WEEKLY BIBLE
STUDY VIRTUALLY AND THROUGH
THIS MINISTRY HE WAS EVEN ABLE
TO GIVE AND- DESERVING-
STUDENTS SCHOLARSHIPS. OF THE
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS. MEMBERS
PASSED THE POPE. DOES IS
CONFIRM AND RECOGNIZE AS THE
MAYOR OF WHAT'S- CERTAINLY HAS
A LONG LEGACY WE APPRECIATE-
HIS FAMILY HIS WIFE AND FAMILY
CHURCH FAMILY ALL THAT KNOW HIM
OUT AS AS BODIES JOURNEY MEMORY
A PAST ORIGINAL PULLED. THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON. MISTER BLOOM
FREER GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO TURN THE MEMORY
OF LEGENDARY FILMMAKER AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
RESIDENT RICHARD DONNER. IF
YOUR DAUGHTER WAS BORN ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN THIRTY
IN NEW YORK CITY TO RUSSIAN
JEWISH PARENTS HIS GRANDFATHER
SMALL MOVIE THEATER IN BROOKLYN
DEEPLY IMPACTED HIS CHILDHOOD
AND SPURRED HIS INTEREST IN
FILM. UPON GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL HE CHOSE TO SERVE HIS
COUNTRY IN THE NAVY AS AN
AERIAL PHOTOGRAPHER BEFORE
LEAVING TO PURSUE AN ACTING
CAREER IN LOS ANGELES WHERE HE
WAS QUICKLY ENCOURAGED TO
BECOME A DIRECTOR DUE TO HIS I.
FOR IMAGERY. HIS FIRST RUN AS A
DIRECTOR WAS FOR DOES HE LIEU
PRODUCTIONS. WHERE HE DIRECTED
COMMERCIALS FOR THE STUDIO
BEFORE MOVING ON TO DIRECT
VARIOUS EPISODES OF POPULAR TV
TV SHOWS SUCH AS- GILLIGAN'S
ISLAND GET SMART THE MAN FROM
UNCLE. AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
TWILIGHT ZONE EPISODES
INCLUDING THE FAMED NIGHTMARE
AT TWENTY THOUSAND FEET. SURE
WE'VE ALL SEEN THAT ONE. MR
DONNER DIRECTED A FEW SMALLER
FILMS BEFORE HIS BREAKTHROUGH
DIRECTORIAL DEBUT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. THE OMEN. STARRING
GREGORY PECK WHICH WAS THE
FIFTH HIGHEST GROSSING FILM
THAT YEAR. TWO YEARS LATER HE
DIRECTED CHRISTOPHER REEVE IN
SUPERMAN WHICH EARNED HIM
INTERNATIONAL RECOGNITION AND
AN OSCAR NOMINATION FOR BEST
DIRECTOR IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE. HE WENT ON TO DIRECT
CLASSICS SUCH AS THE GOONIES
AND LETHAL WEAPON THE LETHAL
WEAPON SERIES BEFORE EXECUTIVE
PRODUCING ALONG WITH HIS WIFE
THE MARVEL X. MEN FILMS OF THE
TWO THOUSAND. RICHARD DONNER
PASSED AWAY ON JULY FIFTH OF
THIS YEAR AT THE AGE OF NINETY
ONE AND IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
OF THIRTY FIVE YEARS. AND CO
PRODUCER LAUREN AND I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BELOW. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JULY SIXTEENTH THROUGH FRIDAY
AUGUST THIRTEENTH IS SUMMER
RECESS MONDAY AUGUST SIXTEENTH
FOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING HEARING OR FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR MCCARTY MOVES MISTER SPEAKER
SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED FOR SUMMER RECESS
PURSUANT TO THE JOINT RULES
UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST SIXTEENTH
AT ONE PM. THE DESK WILL REMAIN-OPEN PURSUANT TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE ARE TURNED.
THANK YOU WALDRON SB ONE FOUR
FOUR I TO NOT VOTING. THANK YOU.
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON'S SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
FOUR I DO NOT VOTING.